waouh ça va ouais ça va ça va ça on est
chauds femmes on est chaud pour cette
deuxième demi-finale qui croît pour les
bonnes régis croit à fond
j'y crois j'y crois mais mais en fait
non il assure défoncer les votes c'est
la catastrophe ada les amis nul les vols
null null null micard bunak amour à la
meilleur potentiel fab abat sur internet
gros potentiel ça joue là j'entends des
bruits de pions la hâte en effet c'est
pas toi j'entends des pions boucher
attaché de spoil à tanger un petit
candidat mais il n'a pas pu fawcett
comme comme 40 ans le match qui joue
avec des français 4 je crois que ferran
de viennoiseries
par contre malgré tout les gens dont le
chat iaaf a tu seras content ils ont
quand même un certain consensus qui est
que malgré un match complètement
inintéressant de de speechless c'est
quand même beaucoup plus intéressant que
que 95 cents enfin dans tous les cas bah
non mais le truc c'est que le monde où
on en a assez parlé avec wade des
parties lentes et tout ça est que ce
fichier est sur les douze parties je
sais pas moi je pense 4 5 d'intérêts 136
maxi d'ailleurs même pas 50% et bon bah
du coup c'est qu'il ya un problème et je
dirais même plus
sur les 4,5 intéressante qui a eu il ya
20% de la partie qui est intéressant
ouais c'est ça c'est qu'en fait il ya le
moment chaud qui arrive on se fait déjà
deux heures créton ça et ça dure dix
quinze minutes 20 et puis c'est revenu
égal il un final qui va faire nul je
veux je veux empêcher gk je vais faire
h3 pas de chance
eh ouais
partie là tu vois on va jusque là
c'était intéressant
il va le mettre tous les âges 3 et puis
bal et de faire une longue mèche mais
peut-être faire tourner autour 3 allée
fait des grimaces à haïti je vois ça je
fais nul est bel et bon jeu de me demi
deux mois saint jouan 5008 bon bah je me
rapproche des bulles quoi la stratégie
peut donc les 4/5 vous pas de petrov
non la petite italienne montoir dès
demain ce sont les italiens avec le truc
d'hier enfin la c1 gambie à machin bras
le corps en gambie sa ligne où tu veux
faire [ __ ] on sait ça est un peu des
fonds sélection je trouve qu'un noir
mais c est censé donner rien mais je
pense pas prendre les bonnes après
pourquoi pas en blitz jeu des pilotes
comme ça puis la selle sur 4,5 alors
très important aussi les vannes a été
champion du monde de blitz en 2010 en
deux jeunes et ce alors qu'une aka
jamais mais bon il ne s'en prendre qu'à
l'idée de points by sheraton nombre de
bits c'est gênant la radio j se bat bien
prononcé speech a jusqu'à présent fait
des bons matches
il danse de partout quoi sert il
il lance ok donc aucune chance
bailly complètement fou il y en a marre
des jalousies n'avait été insupportable
contre maxime un parcours est bon ok
pourquoi pas aux outils du villa font
par contre c'est stream là où il fait
les puzzles rush est tous assez sympa
j'en ai regardé un ok mais il est
impressionnant
ben c'est hallucinant fait ah ben moi
j'ai pas tout regardé mais juste eu un
petit rush séquence way sur twitter va
recruter pas mis d'accord
j'ai mis un hashtag monstre tata est et
était sur le cul amélie permettrait
j'ai regardé toute cette séquence âge
j'ai regardé en entier l'année cinq
minutes et en fait j'ai été impressionné
enfin c'est incroyable en fait ça il
voit tout le toutim propos non mais
c'est lui ai même fait j'ai regardé sur
en live même sur twizz et it explique
quoi yes we can gamble because either
niveau admis state of en fait il sent
les tactiques même il a même pas besoin
de les voir ils sont ils sont vraiment
vite les bons coups mardi c'est qu'un
taux qui marche le des exercices
oui ça génial pour complexifier le truc
des fautes on fait des trucs ou sa
reprise est toujours jacques audiard
normal
ouais ça existe surtout aux tempos je
crois ça peut-être être mis sur chaise
comme mais bon t'as qu'à les pièges ou
des fois tu sais pas si un match il faut
prendre un pion débile pas ça et tu as
aussi tu as aussi des exercices faut
défendre en fait à focale crise suite
fait par mater sais pas si tu as tenté
le puzzle orages sont pas encore non
mais je sois un jour tu apprendras le
bon jeux tenus lundi par des tirs ou et
tout ça à tout le monde est venu le
compare à l'écart ou enfin tu vois je
crois qu'ils car il a fait 55 56 ndiaye
a fait 51 52 donc c'était une grosse
différence
merci 55e
le cinéma est plus tu peux tu montres
plus d'exercices sont durs on va être
monté à 55 56
tu as une grosse différence entre 51 et
55 quoi genre moi j'ai fait 42 et des
grands maîtres décents ils font genre
46,47 tu vois j'ai pas combien fait le
suricate les suricates si l'état est
arrivé à 49 tu vois quelque chose comme
ça c'est le mec s'entraîne à fond ou ce
juste marre il s'entraîne à fond il sung
en fou mais c'est quoi être des
championnats des trucs en même temps que
gta et entraîné tout seul l'asvel en
ferrain
gilles tu peux amener peut-être après y
aura des championnats à ce possible en
tout cas c'est très intéressant
le bestiaire qu'ils demandent c'est qui
le suricate c'est série grande scène en
scène
jojo qui dit qu'il a fait 36 mais 36
c'est déjà bien
je suis pas macho ouais non je ne suis
pas tout le temps 36 ans et plein de
fois je fais je fais 30 32
mais le suricate alors cette partie par
wagon pour le base ball
wen un bouffon e5
et même s'il se fait changer serait un
beau cadeau
donc il est dans un beau spécimen sur
cette pièce la dame prend ça devait pas
se prendre du cavalier calice et 4,4 sur
thème pour moi il est quand même un peu
moins bien mais tout cas plus facile à
jouer avec les noirs non bah ouais mais
après ton qui font passer 5e savane on
ne voit pas le jour tout procès sans
exception si à mettre en avant ses pions
et mais bon je trouve à boudry pourquoi
pas tous pensé y avait quoi stocker ces
quatre j'adore regarder ça il n'y a pas
là y'a pas évident prisa si le ski notre
ya peut-être dame j'ai cinq normales
s'inquiète à me prends cette dame au
québec
retour en f1 en fait quatre turques et
caïques bien leur bond peut faire
maintenant qu'il commence par d'alger 3
ça mange pas de pain ok c'est tout être
humain qui avait 4 ans éprouve
indiquions que ses coups de coeur opposé
à l'as cannes fera juste échange des
souris que ça va faire nul non je pense
parce que pas mal le show cinq ira
peut-être dame b 3 échecs mesrine pas de
tabac - mais là bas donc on imagine toi
tu pourrais fin qu'est le 4k et pour
leucate tourcoing f1 ou pas ou des
points 4 à son premier 8c dans le sens
ou dans l'autre
et ouais bah parce que c'est mon choix
je vois à mon égard mme bardot qu'on
loupe un jeu auquel il peut commencer
par h 4 au 6 mai ça aussi c'est
ambitieux mais bon c'est juste terminent
7es on n'a pas fait recette à fouday
simon ou d'amd cette charge et paper en
vie après 3,2 kg 4 et puis juste
vraiment le tout le moins fort sont pas
disons l'a déjà vu mais la moins bon ça
peut nous faire nul et surtout réforme
ainsi qu'elie des trois mamans
qui est peut-être un peu agaçant non bah
ouais je vais peut-être bizarre et quand
je ne tchate ouais il fait des grimaces
de partout mais bon il fait tout le
temps on était de blizzard s'est fait ce
qui est bizarre c'est quand y fit pas de
tête bizarre
ouais bon bah je sais pas ce que tu les
veux j'espère df2 sans raison pas de
club tous les catholiques ste luce en
prison tu vois que le joue comme ça t'as
pas vu une deuxième qui tombe de bouche
tout bon ben il est malin c'est pas la
bonne ou est-ce qu'on s'attarde même les
partis de l'entente mais icarus et in
fine c'est une bête mais en fait tu le
vois bien sûr le truc de puzzle of
justement parce que là c'est pas des
parties classées juste des positions et
tu vois qu'ils voient plus vite tu vois
ce que je veux dire tu as que
intrinsèquement il est plus fort en fait
[Musique]
et du coup pourquoi pourquoi il est pas
plus fort en vrai quoi si on doit avoir
une mauvaise d'école je vois je vois pas
d'autre explication en fait en fait il
doit être super fort en tactique
peut-être le meilleur du monde mais
voilà parti normalement les autres
voiles et empêche le way un besoin vatin
moment il lui conseille normalement on
va faire des petits yombi dam des
conneries tu vas faire quoi je vous dis
berlinoise et aurait fait comme tout le
monde mais peut-être il doit juste je
sais pas si on voit quoi jeter destin
vienne ajouté ajouté aux landaises
on voit en voie d aragon enfin qu'est ce
qu'on s'en fout
ouais après en langue seniors ce que lui
en fait s'il vous en avoir toutes les
tactiques de partout quoi oui ça ne
marche pas quoi je les ai vus temps et
personne n'a rien vu mais bon tu as tu
as tout vu que la chance la chance
baixas et comme celle qu'on avait fait
contre galles font en fait je suis très
pâle le social
ouais c'était la baïonnette là où jo de
pékin 8-9 cinq mois après son achat ou
celle là ouais on nettoie le savoir je
pense qu'il a réussi à organiser un
blocus ou pas bazas qui essaye de faire
pas mal parce que pour l'instant ce qui
est bien c'est que la dame noire en
plomb je donc l'objet de surveiller g7
et à ce moment-là s'attendait notamment
spam ou pas mal puisque la finale
d'options peut être nu la finale de foot
couleurs opposées peut être nul je
dirais oui pourquoi pas je 4 - très bien
qui est le far west du roi gien et
attendre mais il me sécher quand j'ai
quatre barrages de rage au kiosque de
beaucoup mieux il ya eu un verbe et
quatre peut-être
et puis et puis on se barre de là mais
pas d'échec c'est très bien on s'est
trop y aura pas d'échec ce sera très
bien caché peut-être même a les reins et
les pions qu'on était très heureux et
bon il peut juste car à cause de la
pendule quoi et bonne défense comme à
lorient
si julien keller se trouvait peut-être
deux maîtres-chiens et je pense tu
montes oued oum b3 puis on a trois par
échec
il va revenir à mille à 4 secondes il va
perdre autant de son [ __ ] il va perdre
autant c'est sûr allez vous enfin tu es
trop longs quoi bon
duda il a fait pareil à lille en a perdu
quelques-unes séisme était trop ma
pendule je comprends pas d'où des
retraites va parce que moi j'ai pas
trouvé le match j'avais le foot à deux
places mais
il a moins bien joué que contre contre
sacha et lester qui loterie est battu
jomo cardiaque larry king ouais mais
surtout il a été moins le style du conte
et moi et peut faire pousser trois fous
des cats aussi pour attendre un nom mais
le bien quoique ouais mais peut-être que
tu fais dames quatre dames prend vous
prend et tu montres leroy et essaye de
monter laurent f5 peut-être s'ils
arrivent à temps chez le rat des deux
rois g63 c35 de près du mans d2 ef de
kung fu points donc il fallait il va
tomber quoi l'armée c'est une seconde
bras vous c'est pas assez il faut mettre
de seconde en cinq minutes
il appellera je regardais agassi s'il
est ok tomber quoi rejoint troyes plus
de ce nom peut tout juste 5 plus haut
c'est vraiment l'emploi deux à trois
plus de cheveux très longs
non mais là je suis écoeuré de cette
partie c'est dommage c'est joli bas le
web ainsi constatons bien cinq minutes
leymergie dans une cour non mais du coup
et son gros point fort c'est que en fait
ils comme disait je l'aï fait jamais
d'erreur
ouais mais bon saut je prends la vue
dans ce pitch est trop de magnus juste
humiliés quoi ouais mais 12 a pas assez
fort il réussissait pas le mettre en
danger
bon c'est des gâteaux aux pommes partie
qu'avant vous les robes depuis le 4 5 1
c'est ma qualif est la même à chaque
fois il faut six à l'arrêt charge
d'adobe est raté et tellement
fantastique qui va se voir si jacques
martin buxant et puis qui l'attendent
4050 pour refaire le permettent en fait
je la sens et la pendule fait très
attention ça ça m'intéresse pas ouais
donc ça c'est quoi ça tourne plus
truc cases noires 1 1 est refoulé 5
tonnes sur qui sait si ce jeu vous le
taper pour le fonds 5 pour les trois
jeux blancs pour les noirs ben ouais
ouais
clairement il ya peut-être des
compensations c'était aussi ça rires et
est affaire de fous mais après oui non
peut-être plus ou moins ça se trouve
c'est encore théorique l'atelier oui
analyser mes jeunes elysium heaven hier
c'est fantastique il avait tout analysé
jusqu'au bout quoi c'était génial mais
je bosse pour ça qu'il était très
heureux de ce haut parce qu'en fait il
n'y que soit aussi tout analysé jusqu'au
bout et oui alors que duda tu n'as pas
analysé jusqu'au bout quoi tu ne peux
aller théoriquement jusqu'au 18e
campagne jusqu'au 28e coiffe un nul mais
ouais mais bon tout ça il va il va
apprendre ce boulot-là petit à petit la
linares et c est ce que j avais tu l'as
dit non c'est déjà trop tard tu n'as pas
bien ce sera jamais champion du monde
ouais je démarchais pas encore peut-être
sur la numéro cinq mondial numéro 3 mais
tu sera pas champion du monde
donc tu es nul quoi pas premier tu
connais pas qui est toujours dans
l'excès quoi maintenant il est tellement
dégoûté que ma guise bat tout le monde
qui doit se dire oui lui non plus ne le
battras pas quoi bien trop nul quoi on
n'est pas aux qualités non ok mais est
ce que tu peux pas tu peux pas saquer la
dame ait joué sans âme pas trop en fait
c'est chiant non mais la chance si on
peut mettre un cahier sur e4 tout ça
mais bon d'un coach en f2 et en plus
j'ai vu quoi toucher 5 moi aussi j'aime
et donc n'étaient pas si dures mais
auquel il peut un peu le pion sait s'il
avait un fou de casement en fait je
pense ce serait ok
il ya peut-être eu des affaires toujours
ses sept tours ces huit cavaliers ou ce
nom me stoppe être complètement simple à
gagner mais cédric chartier règne cette
fougère sg 5 fu g6 machin tu pousses bon
les blancs paraître qui conseille ces
deux devises et droit j'ai 3h 4h 5h de
cavaliers place les pièces et il veut
faire c'est 4 c 5 / pour prendre
j'imagine je suis sourd 17 là vous
pourrez échanger tour je pense avec les
noirs donc la dame chance faut garder un
maximum de pièces quand même sur
l'échiquier pour contrôler plus de casse
possible mais ok le quelque part le cul
en d4 il est pas super parce que les
noirs ils vont pouvoir bien attaquer je
peux bien j'ai trois documents il ya
peut-être c'est un endroit peut-être 5
il te fait découverte à la foule en
extase pour le moment bon bah je croyais
pourtant mon esprit que ce que je vais
faire j'ai trop le roi souffle enfant
sur cinq est possible bon après un bon
mois quand même le 35 mai parade et 4
mais je sais pas pas si clair un non
sens pas si claire d'accord ok les
blancs sont mieux ça c'est sûr mais à
quelle belle et peut-être des auberges
et quatre en photo
tu peux pas faire télé ses six petits
défauts prend 1,6
pour cette plongée sur le clouage ça
marchait pas et peut-être des cinq
tickets et c6 maintenant le sens je
pense qu'elle et ses six maintenant et
on vise le plan des quatre noms mais on
vise les envies de cap à fond marathon
gagne des cartes même peut-être les
noirs sont mieux maintenant tu dégages
complètement loi il doit les duels face
aux menaces sur le contact le couple aux
rencontres comptent deux pions et pourra
même échangé les faisant des cats
échanger les fouilles à plus problème
sur le roi il va faire des 3 et 3 des
deux rien dame quoi aller dans l'en-but
des quatre là faut y aller la boum
il est bien la femme mais c'est fini la
ville en sur un homme ayant sur mac à
c'est fini pour eux il peut remarquer à
l'époque carieuse 5 ali mahdi ben
monétisant détroit comme quoi même
nature à tous oui mais attention un
travail fût t shirt pour réfuter chèque
à la fin grafite échec et il aurait pu
te reprendre peut-être car l ie 5 voilà
et prendre cinq coureurs qui feront
savoir ce qu'on veut mais attend bon ok
on prend g4 toupie
bref j'ai acheté des trois est sûre j'ai
5 kg 5e toujours que tu as tourné quatre
après peut-être tour des quatre après ce
que tu entreprends dégâts sur la
carrière trois échecs précis fait des
trois fume et instaure des quatre hommes
je pense et j'ai 5 kg 6 mai autour des 4
encore mieux possiblement attendait 4
fort en fait
roger deux très longues pour l'instant
vers sedan bloqueurs c'est pas le diable
au corps au monde mais messi fait roi
alger 2 est-ce qu'on peut pas le
contourner quoi mais pas pour celui yetu
couet détour ses huit ici je pense sur
ces 8 pourra juste parce que prendre
notre problème sur sur la fuite le jouet
pas trop le problème c'est que senna cas
après un bail des eagles toujours j'en
ai déjà vu dans plein de matches à y
voit des trucs trouvent leurs sources et
les chiens méchants
là il est plus fort qu'eux mais c'est en
fait c'est souvent c'est son plus gros
point fort c'est que dans ce genre de
position tu as la plupart des joueurs y
perdre en ligne et nuit va quand même
tenté un piège mais même pas pour faire
un nul en fait mais pour gagner il peut
te retourner à l'épaule en tombant dans
ce parti savate encore deux minutes on a
la part belle à des bons latins qui
atteint qui est inquiet tuera pas de ya
pas de femmes à la pendule
il peut aussi faire à 5 mai 5 à 4 mais
je pense est un peu lent bah moi je
dirais pour le pion de après tu as le
choix tu peux aussi faire tourner cinq
au quesnoy g8 peut-être battu amélie
cazé fuite et moi j'aurais pas jouer ça
mais bon c'est pas la conduite il fume
autant roger 2 clairement g8 ma ville
avait dû voir un truc qui avait dû
revoir un truc sur tours s'est vite ce
machin et du calcul est un truc il a
calculé mais là j'aime pas trop parce
que cavalli this is us pas ce qui fait
en vertu renvoi est dangereux mais en
fait comment est-ce que tu va virer la
dame tu peux tu as pas accès à ces
quatre appareils
est ce que tu peux tout faire des 5 et 6
4 tu veux dire qu'il pourra pas re
sacrifier la dame sur le pilon à la fin
parce que le québec façon il fait tout
reprend qu'elle prend et f4 direct ouais
ya cinq ans et voir mais avec mon papa
klaatu rendez vite fait qu'il se situe
autour de cette femme attend peut-être
plus simple b 5 à 5 à 4 ok peu mal au
sérieux mais maintenant qu'ils sont
juifs vous êtes leur renvoyer à chf 8
mai à saint qui fixe voilà qui va
bloquer en b 4 et ça libère la tour
ouais c'est ça que je suis va faire que
ye capte au caire ils arrêtent leurs
angles au caire en fait en der mais ce
qui est devenu un homme et que vous
passez du berceau de nom mais il pas
simple à batna comme valet de trouver la
bonne méthode de défense mais c'est joli
ça ça me prend des trois tours des
quatre mois mais il est fort il est fort
maca mais après je sais que je suis et
emma leeuwen et justement vrai petit et
juste avec d'intéressantes crise de
donne moi je pense pas que c'était un
sacrifice de dames prennent la tête est
contrée mais le truc c'est qu'en fait
j'avais l'option isolé en d4
et comme tu as une pièce deux mois avec
les blancs il a réussi juste à l'attaqué
avec tourtour cavaillé contre turda
enfin du coup mathématiquement il était
devant ta 3 content de mes jours pas que
l'arabe à l'époque ému ou d'autres
immeubles mégalo et mars ont lieu là
écoute je sais pas si la dame s'est
activée quoi ouais c'est chiant brigitte
qui sont gagnants mais il est mieux je
vois je vois pas trop le danger en fait
on est noir bonrepaux l'étape et il faut
taper g6 coup j'ai fait un gaffe de
passeront d'un match 4 et chaque si on
bouge le cavaly la bêtise elle bosse
pour ça qu'on est
en proposent non mais tu dois pas que
c'était peut-être faire reiff cinq tours
g4 sinon on te passe bien mais moi c'est
ce que je veux faire au début
non mais je vais pas accepter nul à la
fin tu joues mais c'est pas si simple
force d'opposition
non mais bon le problème c'est que
verizon ont fait pas de même oui voilà
mieux et si c'est passé à 4 mais tu vois
mise à part carlos nmv elle n'a qu'à ta
pas énormément de joueurs qui pouvaient
arnaquer les vols dans la partie
précédente parce qu'il était vraiment
mal nakai il a su période à venir
allaient enfin se voit qu'il est fort un
puzzle rush en fait fin mai mais des
fois je 4 on s'en fout ouais je pense
qu'il faut faire flasher 4 mais bon
cavalier à 3 mal placé il va faire
crisser 2 qui est de 3 kg 4 et puis des
fois tout ce qui me touche au long des 5
est une lancée quatre cavaliers et aussi
à notre plan c'est juste
roy a h1n1 pour faire 4 ou tour j'ai un
g4 g5 toujours un peu comme flavio qui a
eu lieu trop étroit et ça ça il peut pas
faire tout prend 1 3 il ya aussi on
prend bon il ne veut surtout pas prendre
le 6 passes kf prend du coup les potro 6
octobre un québec qui a aidé cette
classique pour protéger le cavalier
libéré à l'est d'alger 3,4 g pas je sais
pas où maintenant trouver peut-être faut
réfléchir un peu là en fait tu prends ta
non c'est génial quoi prends ton temps
non mais peut-être les loteries des cd4
prend de5 des points côté d'autres ont
fait mais tue tous les cases blanches
vêtu et plus dans l'esprit que lui que
je t'en fous je sais tout donner des
gages cet accomplissement où se côtoient
au cou on avait vu un truc car sans une
partie de man et daphné où il ya une
idée comme ça de tout donner
mais bon genre d4 d5 des qualifs cinq
échecs dont les apprendre à me prend et
b dessert on a beaucoup de monde en
moins mais bon
foot est roi mais bon tu n'en est rien
tours a des seins ce moment là j'ai
perdu tout rejet imite pour s'évader roi
est vite fait
moi je suis en effet très bon plus
normal non ce qui peut inclure des jets
capte un jeu ds 1 1 ou d'alger 3 f 4g
cas très plaisir
j 4 j'ai bien aimé vlad parfois quand il
analysé les kouyaté oui ce coût ne peut
pas marcher
tennis est forcément mauvais s'en fout
g4 il va bouger saddam et qui fait j'ai
cinq noms sont de la merde mon roman est
déjà engagé 4 donc des jeunes nous
accordons une victoire morale
avoir quatre singles n'était pas aux
bleus de prendre d'ailleurs c'est pas
juste logique de prendre
ouais s'il prend pas après ces objets
quand même d'aller en h7 non parce que
le pion h6 les dommages 3 contre ce qu
on peut sacrifier h6 laisser-faire
interpète nos parents j'en vois pas ce
que les fouchier prenne plein gaz
peut-être qu'il faut faire dommage
troisième boom voilà enfin quoi le coup
réclamé depuis longtemps et veut faire
damage 3 es fou g5 je pense le tournis
alors attendre et donc du coup sûr on
apprend et la g5 et une fourchette
ouais c'est pas si grave pour m bref
cette gtx mouais mais mais bon ok enfin
de tanger en france
mais bon peut-être il doit faire et
menace qui est rangé 8eme associe quel
point f7 que kate est très pénible aussi
parce que ça fait trois pions après
trois balles c'est mieux que le ca fait
une pièce après et du cou
un rythme à ceux ci j'ai cinq cavaliers
bouche damage 5 dans les menaces plein
de trucs en fait ok moi je suis plutôt
pour les bonnes mais aussi pour qu'ils
lui fils de 2 ans devenant du château
qui se demandaient surtout débat est
reparti enfin des sacrifices c'est sympa
c'est sympa maintenant un motard non je
trouve sympa je ne savais mais a pris
peut quand même être un peu un peu
taquin quoi oui mais ça va déjà m je
trouve par méchant c'est long ça
taquineries mais presque comme un peu
limite un fait mais je sais plus j'ai vu
un truc c'était quand même un peu limite
mais mais bon ouais c'est je pense est
plutôt gentil qui est fou qu'elle jouit
d'un médecin que ce genre le truc avec
moi ce chemin ouais il ya des trucs avec
maurice h et avait cru qu'avec robert
est aussi a pas longtemps dans les
commentaires je me dis oui le pauvre on
aura je pense était champex tu es
méchant mais bon c'est qu'elle vit
encore sa gueule je sais pas quand ils
proposent des coûts je paye qui soit
c'est chic and move et il propose
environ et non ici ce geste bas de
mouvements fin à chaque fois il le
défoncer quand tu vois que à 6 10 et un
truc c'est plus ou moins défoncés
mais bon on avait des commentaires de
claude est quoi ouais c'est ça c'est un
peu dans le style de valérie goal com
l'admets oui avec ce truc à café mais je
pense que c'est pour rire mais je le
connais pas assez en fait mais même
laurent il racontait qu'il était super
fait chambrer il ya chaque fois que tu
perds une partie vient il te changera
maximum il sera un portable
laurent il en peut plus froid mais
laurent en fait j'ai compris c'est le
souffre douleur de tout le top niveau
c'est horrible tout et tous lowey phone
se fout de sa gueule c'est horrible
c'est d amy st elle est pauvre pauvre
laurent blanc mais là du coup il ya
quand même dame n 5 bat sonore non oui
mais j'ai requis il faut parer à ce que
damas f 5 3 6 3
g6 enfin bref tout est pareil après son
attaque ex otages et huit parmi cette
menace sûrement g5 aussi puisque quand
tout cas les bougies afssa tmc bien
chaud voire j'ai cité chaque et on
pouffe la dame donc il ya beaucoup trop
de marge pour la france et qu'il faut
faire ce qu'on fait mais intéressante il
n'a qu'à quidam ans il a trouvé un truc
le casse couilles mais alors retrouve
six ont exigé cinq de faire quand on
veut faire bouger ça je pense si on
prend la fuite dont j'ai un ouais ça pue
trop ça tu veux pas survivre à toutes
les pièces bloquer les dames et les
blancs sont tous les ans normalement
normalement c'est fini gagner mais ça
c'est une cro et damas trois pourquoi
fou prend et orge et injuste d'affaires
reste six matches trois quatre cinq et
on va pas leur nom ça bas ok vous
calcule pas et dames g4 avoir ça doit te
perdu peut-être tour g4 après tour gère
alors peut-être cavaliers qui revient
life 600 f 4 juillet quand même mais bon
sur damas je crois direct il peut quand
même te faire qu'un voyage sont ok
peut-être qu'il faut être malin alors ok
c'est bon ils la jouent en force normal
c'est pas mal l'escalier ouais c'est
quoi la défense qui assure toujours
général veut faire quoi et kg 6
alors malgré cet attentat du coup comme
il a déjà tout n'a que l'allemagne et
oublie t il vraiment pharynx mais
d'autres il a juste gagné cette partie
va défendre l'amérique ces trois pièces
complètes ur freak on a tous perdus
après si tu peux sol rachat font mais
faut peut-être faire tour g1 quand même
sur qui j'ai six dames f5
on change de ma bd de la maternelle 5
juin ce matin en deux quand même 1 5 me
je suis moi j'ai cet événement h4 je
pensais puisque hk 3 et 8 h 5
oui pour projet s'y est opposée j'ai pas
encore vu ce bien dessus l'homme prend
la fuite ce hoquet de s'être tu as mal
si c'est bien joué je pense oui mais là
c'est alger 6 mater menace d'un match 8
matchs des affaires de vol ok tu peux
pas avoir un truc propres tu peux
prendre prendra aussi ces dames français
7 mais c'est pas si énorme que ça non il
va faire du cac et prend 1,4 et c'est
une jolie d'artillerie ouais ouais ouais
ouais
du coup ce à quoi les manèges la statue
géante 4 jusqu'à deux de mes fils qui
les font toujours ce fichier magnifique
ya peut-être d'algisi trois des huit
tours et sète way
peut-être que je suis content dans
voyage 4 je sais enfin moi je pousse mon
pull en fait déjà femme athée autant de
garder cette tour en a huit lab a bloqué
quatre lauréates d'avoir aidé à manger
soit ouais mais ça tu veux pas mais
juste le rêve parce que le roi 8 blocs
la tour est native jamais tous h à fond
mais qu'est ce que c'est un moment b4
bon c'est un coup à la cheville il a dû
calculer une idée bah il faut c'est que
vous enfermez le fou concernés sans fil
3g de j'imagine enfonçant fishie s'en
fiche a pas cent fischer il va pas s'en
fichent longtemps que la 4g nina cas
quand même mais on sait tous les coups
quelque chose qui voulaient pas se faire
enfermer le roi il devra décider de
maths avec tours g8 et iccat qui
arrivait et tu peux te faire mater je
sais pas
j'imagine que c'est mais assez chaud qui
minent l'école des blancs non je pense
les blancs quand même non ouais mais y'a
peut-être juste un père baisse de 12
peut-être j'espère fait dans tous les
cas sans feu
je compte aussi mais je suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse être mieux mais que mon nom
et je pensais qu'il avait minimum perf
est en fait c'est pour ça mais si je
double cle pions pas voilà on n'est plus
mais c'est sûr qu'il va faire
même mal pas vous mais moi la pendule on
est malade ou quoi l'armée n'a cassé un
ton roi des cinq attention et qu'elle
bénéficie ce nom mais n'a cassé pour les
bons dossiers chauds ne pas gagner une
partie comme ça t'inspire et qui joue
bien qui est pas assez c'est même pas
pour gagner cet autre mini va la perdre
même probablement il va la perdre
ok les a peut-être poussé cinq prises
prises qui a eu quatre échecs mais
lecavalier a fait du mal à revenir
arrêté deux pions à 6 non mais c'est
impressionnant par an non mais je pense
est fou c'est ça qui allait prendre
qu'un échec mais ça n'aurait pas
fonctionné
ouais j'sais pas comment ils sont sans
les bonnes à parent perpète
ouais mais bon les pièces autos bon bah
voilà
ayé violent n'a qu'un trop fort trop
faim mais on risque de voir ça
aujourd'hui demain tous les jours en
fait n'a pas de il n'y a pas
d'opposition au lancement par ménaka
c'est donc du caucus soit celle en de
berlinoises avec les structures
symétrique s'est jamais passionnant jeu
là le gros problème c'est que les jeunes
vous qui répondent quand même rapidement
et nakai unis l'auteur des cinq s'est
défoulé 4 est la preuve en dessin qui
vont fermer ont fait quelques jeux pour
faire des saints qui va y arriver il y
aura aussi prend des métriques nuls très
désolé c'est très connu mais cette 32e
du coup essayer de jouer la majorité a
droit à un an
je sais pas si tu veux faire un petit
bout pour gagner ce jeu vous pour faire
mieux c'est pour ça que c'est justement
pour faire mieux avec les mains en photo
là il peut faire nul comme il veut nous
faire dame e3 mais bonjour je suis fou
de 3,5 échanger et faire nul non mais
oui parfaitement parce que du coup n'a
qu'à elle est déjà gagné deux parties où
il était moins bien mais que non
mais ça montre quand même la différence
de niveau de gagner en étant leur bien
en tête qu'ils nous montrent pourquoi
car je ne veux pas cette année à cause
du match de championnat du monde
j'imagine
ouais mais fabiano à jouer ouais il
fallait bien non il a tout joué
ouais bon il a perdu 8 contre à rognan
mais bon le moins de juin
je sais pas si je la prod chasse ligue
magnus
je suis intéressé de gémir la liste n'y
a pas de liste en fait pour le moment
mais bon quand bien même il y ait ce qui
va vraiment jouer ou est-ce qui va jouer
comme l'année dernière de trois matchs
fait sensé jouer contre lui en fait le
premier match 11
enfin contre lui hammer je penserai à
l'équipe ses joueurs car hansen hammer
tahri est un enfant au dernier du coup
c'est peut-être pas je pense que si
c'est cette équipe alignée c'est juste
la meilleure équipe de la ligue
clairement comme le tome i gueye encore
un pion il a gagné un set mais je pense
quand même nul le roi blanc assez fermé
mais bon j'avais quelque chose de d'un
truc c'est juste rien de buzz mind
chanson like your dame c4 en fait sur
deux points 16 mai c'est rien de grave
ne faisons comme si rien n'est dupe
en 2008 où vas-tu nul ouais on va vendre
ce type id évidemment c'était promis
quoi le show d'ouverture c'était pro
bowl et les vols de quoi c'était pourri
oui on se prenant juste et paris s'était
promis dans mes films mais si c'était un
premier bond tokyo norme la plus ou
moins la même c'est intéressant que le
téléphone va voir s'il joue pareil ça
m'étonnerait que qui en fait j'ai 5 h 4
mai g5 les caf
voilà hip-hop g4 france à celui-là
venezuela 3 et gta 4 7 et donc c'est
quand on peut h 30
il va préparer ok donc normalement avec
les blancs on veut réaliser des quatre
dans ce genre de position pour le fou g3
fasse un truc sur cinq
bon là pour l'instant des quatre chiens
ne sont que 44 ou c'est pas trop le
moment mais en gros quoi mais je réagis
l'axé souvent plus ou moins égales nom
aussi quand les noirs ont réussi à se
développer
ouais après rush 1 pas mal comme ça si l
on se prend caillage cinq étrangers 3,9
donc on est content
car j'en suis quand même dommage pour
toi que le meilleur ne le joue pas mais
d'un autre côté je comprends aussi
magnus comme ighil a gagné quand même
très facilement les deux premières
éditions
c'est difficile aussi gagnent tout un
c'est dur quand tu gagnes tout comme ça
trop dur de vie plus longue et une trop
non mais tu gagnes tout est fait je
passe difficile d'être motivés pour tout
fashion ce titre de champion du monde
c'était vraiment important pour lui et
pas un autre côté et d'un autre côté le
speech est ce enfin qu'il gagne une
nouvelle fois ou pas en fait ça change
rien c'est qui les plus forts
et du coup c'est pas trés challenge en
quoi pour lui j'imagine c'est la super
toit pour duda qui a fait rêver sur deux
matches
ouais après on verra s'ils confirment un
os que il les a un peu pris par surprise
on verra mais il est jeune il peut
encore progresser
dambach l'avant font défaut principal
c'est qu'il a un parti fort d'ouverture
de marne pour poursuivre et lula ouais
répertoire bien meilleur que le mien
c'est pas tout est relatif mais
justement par rapport à des joueurs de
ce niveau là eux s'y passe mais donc
basse et c'est carrément le truc qui
doit améliorer et c'est facile en fait
quand tu sais quel est ton défaut tu
sais sur quoi travailler après d'un
autre côté il sera obligé de changer son
style comme tous les autres à petit à
petit mais bon on maquille qu'ils soient
fougue un peu pendant un moment et puis
si jamais ça marche vraiment pas mais
évoluera naturellement là mais est ce
qu'il pourra faire c'est sur la question
que tu te poses avec ses joueurs qui
montrent un peu comme oui tu verras
quand ils sont fougueux qui sont très
forts et tu te demandes si pas faire le
switch et d'ailleurs on peut parler de
naka aussi qu'il ya un peu ce même style
et bokeda cahill après il réussit sa
carrière un plateau il était top 10
tournois et megal pendant dix ans ok pas
champions du monde mais ces jo t'en a
pas 50 des gens comme une onde larry
scott arrive même à menacer pour le
titre ou pas puisque d'un cas il a pas
on aurait pu penser à un moment donné
qui menacerait ben fait
jamais eu de match mais il s'est
qualifié pour les candidats plusieurs
fois c'est déjà quelque chose
ouais mais il n'a pas menacé bah après
non parce que tu as menée par exemple il
ya un style un peu fougueux louis aragon
n'a pas menacé non plus quelque part
alors que ya peu encore plus longtemps
il était numéro deux de l'armée les
candidats c'est mal fait mais il a quand
même menacé il ya une fois des candidats
il s'écroule à la fin mais il était
quand même dans l'est dans les premières
places
non mais devient tournant aussi c'était
l'année ou à nantes gagnent la première
règle non de le bas et alors qu'en fait
il a joué son espagnol a aucune un pion
il ya des trucs qui marchent est des
fous projet de 20 blizzard a fait qu'il
ait pas non mais oui n'est pas si j'ai
appris par un tournoi puis il a fait une
anglaise fisac les blancs je sais plus
léger une petite idée mais sa venue
assez vite et du boost à ses clacs non
mais il a plus menacées dans le sens où
il a quand même été clairement numéro
deux mondial les mamans l'image les
ménages pauvres du monde
alors que dacca tu l'a jamais ils
mettent leur champion du monde
par là il perd le pion détroit par
contre s'il prend tout sur ado il peut
prendre des trois mais bon il y aura la
case des cinq notes lourdes vient
d'ailleurs à la case f5 sur les cahiers
et on s'éclipse
c'est pour ça qu'ils préparent tour à
sept tours à huit il veut forcer fou
prend pour faire est franc et du coup il
va contrôler la case f5 et maintenant il
faut qu'ils contrôlent la case f5 malema
n'associe tour prend un pied prend des
trois maintenant van well et tours à
huit et a gagné la colonnade pour à
cette dame prend 1,7 il va rentrer et où
il est passé mais on n'est pas mieux que
le monde non tu te fais dominé va
certainement maire de mareuil avec les
noirs y tient avec les blancs il a du
mal non mais du coup c'est sa circulaire
c'est que l'on sait pas si duda tu vois
est ce que parent je pense que tu as ce
changement de style
il peut être assez difficile à effectuer
et tu sais pas vraiment si tu peux y
arriver ou pas qu'est ce que ce que ça
oui les bleus quoi mais justement fort
on est d'être nommé la donne et d'être
enfin pu perdre cette partie dans vingt
coups parce que il est rentré sur la
colonne nae machin mais là tu la mets
selle après six rencontres
c'est en complet mais c'est la pression
et jusque c'est difficile d'être sous
pression pendant toute la partie
c'est le problème comptes n'a cassé que
tu es obligé d'être alerte aux taxis
tout le temps et un moment donné tu un
peu plus non mais la preuve le choix
s'était affaissé et puis tu en as marre
très tu as peur introduire trois heures
je voudrais juste dizaine le match dès
maintenant en fait les orphelins 27
pareil je me fous des quatre matches 1
bien sûr on va nouvelle nul n'est pas
génial colin strause chine n'accueille
pas il va t elle changer
comme tout à l'heure il avait il à l'afp
elle va modifier un truc un jour mais je
vois pas pouvait qu'être obligé prises
et d'obliger répondait 5 et c'est
toujours un truc que re5 dame en recul
tous les tours adverses auquel jour
pareil très vite la rb c'est sûr y'a
rien c'est le néant nouvelles
suggestions idiote venu en pronostics
alors après les départage avant
maintenant c'est cardiokine qui dit oui
il faut faire 11 13 parties ah oui j'ai
vu le mec et blanc ils soient obligés de
gagner mais c'est les champions du monde
mais en fait tu vas tu prends les noirs
déjà par contre il a très bien vu que
c'est les noirs sont souvent mieux
encore ce match ce soir c'est pas une
bonne idée battus en amical et blanc a
juste perdu le match d'avant occasion
ouais mais en fait je pense qu'il ya
rien à faire
enfin il faut se faire une raison que ce
n'est pas spectaculaire et que ce sera
toujours nul et puis c'est tout en fait
ouais enfin s'il faut arrêter de se
prendre la tête en disant ouais c'est
parti là ils sont ennuyeuses machin fait
on le sait c'est ennuyeux mais en fait
le premier c'est le jeu c'est pas les
joueurs c'est même pas les règles en
fait je pense
ou alors faire comme eux manu pour
rajouter un janus tu es déjà nice de
partout non mais en fait c'est pas idiot
que les visuels sont très intéressantes
avec les janus jeu comment le genou ce
alors le janus il fait fou et cavaliers
en même temps c'est très fort un janus
est-ce que c'est plus fort qu'une dame
non on annonce une opposition
on estime à 6 points 6 points et demi
mais difficile à utiliser peut-être six
points et demi après c'est qu'en milieu
de jeu il peut se faire attaquer par les
foules et qui avait lieu la nuit signe
et surtout fort en finale tu le caches
en faudrait un jour histoire est par
contre en finale il est monstrueux il
défonce et tour a en fait ils te fais
des échecs de partout ils reculent en
cavalier et le janus seul qu'est ce qui
peut faire maths échec et mat sol mais
du coup ça il faut du janus de partout
quoi qui peut s'asseoir à la table de
jeu ne soit pas un génie c'est
fantastique comme pièce je vais avec
manu du coup plein de fois on a commenté
on est on a commencé à changer les piles
à se demander ce qui se passe et si au
lieu dé finale deux tours c'était une
finale de janus est beaucoup plus
intéressant mais très très tactique est
difficile de jouer janus contre janus
quoi parce que toutes les cases sont
contrôlés enfin ce tarif une case
blanche
enfin donc le jeune reda tu as tout
reposait pas ils sont de toutes les
cases c'est très fort en fait un janus
matches passent et fantastique
manu me disais que manu side et janus
dans sa poche
qu'est ce qu'être faisais attention très
vigilant qui ne sens pas son génie
humain fût très heureux de cette pièce
quoi mais c'est marrant comme kia sépare
de change mais songe paul des vikings si
quand tu as besoin de jeu de janus pour
rendre un scream regardable ouais mais
c'est ça en fait ces cov le janus peux
te sauver quand tu stream aussi mais bon
enfin ou alors ils bouffent effet j'ai
cinq balles a suivi si la tour d2
c'était un planus à la mettait aux
prises pas par exemple voilà 7 à 5
ok mais on doit gagner ce match rien à
ma vie la fesci 4 avec les blancs il
faisait 5 et noir ok mais je sais pas si
c'est juste pour des 6 3 1 6 litre et
qu'un autre juste également c'est juste
égal temps des six
bon ben kay qui bouge la tête
c'est à dire mécontent bat g pareil
calculent-ils et il fait un mouvement de
tête perplexe voile et l'a fait une
grimace quand même chiant pour être qu'à
ça lui a pas plu à 6-5 face à ces bons
films en vo c'est simple tu prend 1,5 en
france et 16 tours 2 et puis tu es
chandre de peu c'est ce que j'avais km à
l'est quand on me l'a fait j'ai 5 pi
rien
et du coup on a pensé quoi départage la
départage du match en phase ou bien on
n'a pas trop aimé mais bon s'ils avaient
déjà nous ça aurait été plus drôle je
vois rien faire à 4 tours 4 florian lui
demande ce qu'on a dans une carriè
kingdoms certains d'entre eux seront pas
des couffins normalement t'es content
c'est un gugusse comme moi quoi mes
carnets qu'il ya deux ans était le
finaliste de taille à faire son rôle
supposé des coups d'envoi mais parce que
c'est lui qui a accepté un traité bah
oui c'est lui je conviens mais s'y
trouvaient cinq millions il n'aurait pas
accepté
non mais totti le trouve brillant mais
qu'il a reçu de l'argent là c'est fait
pour cette illumination
mais je pense pas qu'ils étaient payés
pour faire le clown noir dont ils
auraient été payés pour faire ça en fait
mais qu'est ce que j'en savais mais
pourquoi faire des farces à taux
courants fois je ne sais pas mais
pourquoi ils auraient été payés pour
pourquoi pas un message courant bien
réussir quel est l'intérêt de payer
quelqu'un pour venir ça en fait ça sert
à rien donc
et ouais pour les départage c'est la
fidh
hawking qui sait ce que s'il fait froid
et fille tu peux avoir h 5e et du coup
tu te fais même contrée non mais je
pense pas qu'ils étaient payés non mais
c'est pas possible en fait de payer les
lampes ou dans les rares voix mais sa
part et puis s'en va
marié il voulait jouer son b4 il s'était
trompé de pions quoi et puis il n'y a
pas d'âme b6
je sais que ça donne pas grand chose en
fait mais il aurait pu faire mais en
fait jamais j'ai jamais reconnu les gens
qui donnait le coup d'envoi en fait
c'est fait avec le kayak ligne que j'ai
reconnue fa les autres personnes ses
revenus que je connaissais pas être un
acteur si futile et il y avait expédié
la fille mais je savais pas que ce thème
à être connu en angleterre
la fille de hockin le faith and the crm
hébergé par premier nom de chaque fois
que cette approche me potié une fiv un
juge a lu film chapeau plat des éléments
et mais c'est quoi ce g3 l'afp non mais
on avait vu des partis comme ça de
hargne en gîte ou moins que les noirs
contre un quart en un an le match s mais
arnaud juste à côté noir et ça va être
très bien sorti mais c'est souvent mieux
et donc est ce que je sais pas trop qui
doit uniquement des est-ce que c'est
utile ce truc de fou nombre de documents
valides non non mais c'est pour ça que
c'est pour ça qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
payés pour faire lé coup d'envoi soit
possible mais je comprends pas en fait
non mais quand c'est des célébrités je
comprend mais mais même en fait
enfin pour la première ronde en fait je
comprends alors le coup d'envoi du match
mais à chaque partie je comprends pas
trop le truc est surtout choquant comme
quoi il leur fait jouer des vrais coup
je passe comme si tu faisais le coup
d'envoi au foot qui lance le ballon
égaré sur tout de suite joué comme un
fou c'est une passe comme si ces patrons
voyous qui font du coup d'envoi fictif
il et puis après le match commence alors
que c'était des vrais coup d'envoi non
mais en fait peut-être qu'ils devraient
venir dire la phrase de larbitre menora
puyehue je cois ouais bah c'est mieux
que de jouer un couvent jeu pour envoyer
flash ou tapis sur la pendule tête mais
bon on peut acheter un produit serait
capable de se tromper de boutons mais
non mais je voulais un coup pourquoi pas
mais que ce soit un vrai truc fictif en
fait fin que ça soit pas le vrai premier
coup de la partie c'est trop bizarre ce
truc je ne méritais en fait le cerveau
tu es bien été obligé de jouer le coup
que je décide quoi ouais mais tu as vu
comme un paria qui il a voulu faire il
on changeait quoi des quatre sites où tu
joues b4 enfin comme dans les tournois
d'ordinateurs avec les premiers coups
forcé fait ce serait une idée ça mais
bon tu vas même le format du speech est
1re nettement c'est difficile de faire
des bons formats parce que là c'est trop
déséquilibrée n'investit chess d'un truc
pas mal pour que le meilleur gagne quoi
mais le truc c'est que c'était vraiment
trop fort tu as vraiment cartonné mais
c'est comme ça leur fait faire comme ils
l'ont fait dans un roman au poker c'est
pas poker c'est au saccage jeu il est
tournoi était était ouvert à tous bon
soft young art il ya eu trois amendes
ouais championnat du monde en fait
ouvert à tout le monde ça passe tune
garder âge tu joues trop bien tu ne vous
intéresse pas tu pourras jouer
d'ailleurs tu seras plus jamais champion
du belge jean faire pareil car c'est là
de chance que tu seras toujours film
s'appellera de jouer avec arsène est
vraiment fort c'est impressionnant quand
même là là là il ya pas content que le
match j'ai pas trouvé de louche de
fantastique percée nar avait solidement
mes souliers de fétilly plus fort car on
est juste on l'a vu dans match car on a
eu une chance en huit mois après la 6
options veut mais j'étais pas bien
défendu et le gars en 36 c'est bon c'est
bien visible personnes le même
incompréhensible de voir ce qui se passe
donc ça c'est par une occasion ratée il
a fait ce qu'il a pu dépenses mais c'est
la vie quoi c'est son coût de l'âge 3
est en fait tu joues à 3pts être humain
du de pâtes champion du monde mais c'est
comme ça peut-être que ce que tu mérites
nom et la force de 40 cents surtout
qu'ils défendent bien tu as même la
partie stella qu'elle l'a 3 avec les
blancs où il aurait pu être un tout
petit peu en danger il a failli tout de
suite cela devrait finale le candidat
black anticipée autour des 8 aurait là
de exact est un pion que je me tais toi
en fait il est seul fait s'il me fait
mal
monsieur pratique fait il me fait penser
plus à djoko que nadal ce que djoko tu
vois il fait jamais rien de trop
impressionnant non plus enfin quand tu
regardes les matchs djoko ya rien de
super impressionnant mais en fait c'est
la régularité qui est impressionnante et
je pensais carlson aussi c'est ça qui
est impressionnant c'est la régularité
de me une fois j'avais dit que carson je
pensais que c'était djoko le faire
comparaître sportif j'ai pris de jeu
pour mais sûrement après toujours dur de
comparer les sports mais c'est souvent
c'est celui qui ressemble le plus un
puisque nadal res canada il a quand même
un coup fort navail la cam un coup fort
ces différentes nana il à son coup droit
est ok il peut te domine avec le coup
droit
karl sévère marcassins ya des finales à
personne il avait position iranien ouais
je sais pas si c'est plus nadal ou djoko
mais en tout cas c'est dans ce sens là
c'est par rapport aux jo ce que je mets
même finalement bon ça chauffe ça
dommage seulement il a pris la bonne
décision et que s'est tenue la deuxième
ronde
juste je peux pas cautionner quoi
certainement pas plus un peu le truc
mais après c'était tellement massacrant
les départage que tu dises min et le
march é peut juste faire ça ils sont
mais bon le truc c'est qu'on est
incroyable
on avait tous disent avant-match pas
quand j'ai écrit d'article chose comme
c'est lé clair j'ai mis je ne vois pas
que mon corps ne peut rivaliser en
rapide il faut qu il ya un an et 12 en
after la diva on a dit tout le temps et
on n'est pas les seuls
tout le monde est au courant d'autres
sauf lui non j'ai vu là il a donné une
bonne éducation et hier là-dessus
fatidique pour les sponsors mais j'ai la
même chose en live d'ailleurs enfin
parce que j'avais parlé avec l'adav en
vêtements mais mais en fait pour les
sponsors c'est bien d'aller jusqu'aux
des partages et comme disait vlad
maintenant c'est une vraie économie d
les seconds c'est une vraie économie
c'est à dire que tu as tu et à toi mais
y'a pas que toi tu as tout un tas de
gens que tu payes et qui vive
- at-on crochet quelque part et par
ndong en fait allé au départage quand tu
es allé aux états unis pour prendre des
sponsors pour être invité de partout et
où tu t'es pas féminine humilié tu as
fait match nul en partie en partie
longue et ajuste normes et partage il se
serait jamais fait humilier pour autant
nains battre il a fait ce qu'il a pu en
fait le truc c'est que je pense qu'il
avait pu gagner leur nom mais dans la
tête dans la tête d'un moment il dit si
je prend beaucoup de risques peut-être
je perds de 2,3 points est bon la norme
aimé son match mais bon voilà on dise
non à la rigueur début du match plutôt
solide jeu solide
je vais monter la pression qu'il ya la
ceinture mais avec l'afrique est prévu
plus équipe arriver mais ça c'est
armandie vous voulez gagner la joie non
mais ça c'est sûr mais juste il n'a pas
voulu jouer sur tous les azimuts dès la
première ronde clairement il a fait
trois roues sonimaux il voulait rentrer
dans le match s'est initié à 3 3 je
pense vous dirigez un point par la route
relie mots pourquoi pas la première très
très mal passé après les autres bons
surtout lassé de la route 3 avec les
food des deux tours points semble banon
mais si je te reprend 1,5 illustre mieux
les deux dames 1 damas at oui moyens peu
mieux mais permettez comme plan ne pas
tu mets ta dam en a 7 est avancé de long
terme si on refait une troisième fois un
truc avec des quatre qui étaient hamas à
ce point là c'est tout le monde nous
connaissait même ictoi de la chance là
le maître connaît pas manquer à
l'univers il connaît pas en fait majoral
pas connue mais moi j'y vois je viens de
me glisser sur qui connaît c'est
obligatoire qui connaissent donc non
mais magnus qui est plutôt bien préparé
je trouve
il a pas trop grand chose avec les
blancs mais en tout cas canal plus de
soucis que j'ai vu toute la première
chez sony corp ont été le fait mach iii
et la deuxième au site chimique off où
il a raté tourer ouais mais là j'ai
appris je comprends qu'il ratera un
trouble de l'expliquer donc j'ai pas
dire son nom mais ce à quoi je devrais
avoir été préparé plus juste pour le
mais en fait ils jouent les quatre
nouveautés faire icône ajoute ou vite et
ok c'est le moment où vraiment critique
mais en fait tu dois connaître jusque là
le seul à connaître en fait parce que tu
connais pas je comprends que tu joues
tours à 30 mais c'est pour ça que
caruana en fait c'est un fail a
peut-être pas meilleur que lui par
dessus elle est vraiment numéro deux
mondial il fait quand même un très bon
match en réalité maintenant il faut un
bon match johan tu dis je vais donner
une fantastique oui quand-même grosse
bourde ou quoi
mais karl sa note sur ses chances c'est
comme ça je pense que si tu essaies de
faire un beau match que tu vas te fais
tu vas te prendre comme nous d'ailleurs
contre sow tu vas te faire contrer cette
attaque peut-être pas l'aborder du beau
jeu entre deux pour gagner un titre de
champion du monde donc je vais pas
critiquer la fin juste que tu peux tu
peux juste pas le faire contre carl
scène il est trop fort et si tu essayes
de faire le beau j'en fais tu vas te
faire passer de partout et contrairement
au tennis ou tu t'en fous de perdre 6 2
6 2 6 2 en fait tu t'en fous pas te
faire des français et tu te prends je
crois plus qu'à traverser ma seule
chance de gagner
je préfère perdre dix fois et en gagnant
que 2 que d'en faire honte si si c'est
perrault départager mais t'as un truc
des sponsors et tout ça c'est vrai c'est
c'est vrai comme truc tu as une réalité
économique quoi tu te dis que tu as
quand même des chances et que tu fais ça
et puis tu vas comment ça se passe mais
je me sens de roches entre la fin on
connaît l'historique entre les deux non
mais moi ils auraient pu gagner ladoire
là et puis beaucoup de parties par mail
à xii aurait pu bien se passer
oui oui et justement le passé mais l'oms
pour match était ok mais c'est la xii
fait c'est juste qu'au lieu de tout
miser dès la première ronde et de faire
une guerre sur tous les azimuts
il a réduit le match il a voulu réduire
le match à quatre parties en fait
et probablement pas assez surtout qu'en
plus tu fallait garder les bonnes près
parce je veux faire ça peut-être foyer
jusqu'à chetta schennikov jusqu'au bout
et du coup la sortir partis disent
peut-être si tu vas faire ça jusqu'à ce
qui va faire demain
mais peut-être que s'ils gagnent ils la
gagnent trop tôt en fait c'est ce qu'il
faut attendre suis pas comme quoi tu
contre le psg quoi tu attends oui ça
doit être un huitième quatuor en liga en
fait je vous que le psg pour les bacs le
maire au risque même de marquer à la
toute fin quoi de faire un match débit
de tenir 0-0 il se passe rien mais bon
déjà on y arrive pas oui déjà on n'y
arrive pas alors c'est la seule chance
que sinon en fait ils vont toute façon
ils vont égaliser à un moment donné ce
sera fini capa kf3 la meilleure approche
g3 est rien encore 7 secondes marley ne
perd pas tout avec les blancs quoi il
peut la perdre comme ça hop hop hop
il peut la perdre quand même un peu
longuet news à l'étranger simple il faut
que les lions prime ou fly plus vite la
fri v8 échec échec échec arrive à faire
mieux ben tre rapide à macaye ce marin
se marient se marque c'est fantastique
et on sent de sur son fils d'éleveur
arrêter quoi que c'est vrai on ne veut
plus voir zack wright 25 minutes à cause
de votre tournée de trucs
ça nous donne envie de parler d'autre
chose vous devez à commenter cet article
ça commence c'est toujours la même
partie ah non là ça a changé là ça
change et là ça change et on recommence
du conte peu en deçà du coup ça
ressemble on n'avait pas une salle
carrés contenant le match perd en scène
car ils tiennent justement quand on
compte on y parlait avec le pion dessin
qui n'est pas une cavité qui avait été
joué comme ça je sais pas mais personne
n'a gagné parti de pas mal comme ça
n'est pas si longtemps la date tardive
mais brouillon c'est fantastique
ouais en fait avant le match tu sais
déjà que tu vas perdre ses choix au
courant le truc commence peut-être pas
dans les dix premières lui qui est oui
bon j'ai fait nuit là la première
l'addition juste milieu en fait après 30
minutes de match puis tueur sait déjà qu
plus que ta pierre duclos 9 attention
devrait peut-être faire des saints aux
être là l'année prochaine y aura
peut-être qu'ils appuient d'année
prochaine ira peut-être firoud déjà pour
robin laurent il pense que lausanne hier
fois par tout le monde pense qu'à
devenir fort mais j'ai envie de te lèves
l'anoci pensé très fort c'est tout ce
qui est trés formulaire mais personne
lui conseille d'arrêter de faire des
missions internet parce qu'en fait ils
banon mais je dirais mans il va se
défoncer observons quoi peut-être que
personne ne sait qui fait quoi
tout ce qui fait que nous la voix n'a
progressé très marrante jour des beats
sur internet et machins et le gabon cui
ferroudja donc que ces jeunes iraniens
il a pas 14 15 15 15 il ya quinze ans il
est déjà de 1600 il joue bien d'accord
mais en fait il fait des stream il fait
tous les arénas des bullet 3000 en bus
bien mais mais en fait c'est qu'on le
gâchis total enfin faire ça quand tu
peux peut-être des deux champions du
monde réel
un peu comme naka peut-être après bon ça
leur donne des réflexes car fait des
trucs mais je sais pas en f1 et moi juge
le tarn et les échecs
mais pour la prod szczecin guile
recrutables un nom et parler mais s est
pas mal mais il demande samba à ce jeu
là c'est un innocent par mathieu s'est
pas trop charme
on préfère mais qui veulent vraiment
jouer pour jouer ouais le point en fait
s'il faisait pas enfin si compter comme
local j'aurais pris quand même parce que
pour les bah oui dans les excellents
pour 2006 mais n'a en fait le truc c'est
que du coup franc à rivaux avec lui
quand arrive aux playoffs et que tu mets
la gare de fuir ou dja est et d'où dab
dab en plus serrés style qui sont
horribles c'est vrai que les trois
relaxes super bien je pense évidemment
pas assez horrible fait fin c'est ta
trois mois c'était mieux veut ou sochaux
faute non mais en plus et on voit bien
dans le match la naca les vols c'est que
quand ça t'arrive une partie que tu
contraint à carnac
ça t'arrive prendre une partie bon tu
toi tu résistes machin de toutes les
tactiques
ok tu t'en prends un deuxième que tout
le temps qu on est enfin temps à trois
d'affilée la toile ils vont bien faire
floquer dégâts sur fais-moi une
fourchette connais pas un chef moins
vite
ouais je veux pas souffrir bien fait
c'est un peu comme trois dragons de
komodo vont qui envoie pas des double
six mais je sais pas il envoie des 5,4
enfin foo fighters font toujours plus
que double 3 quoi tout temps il faut
entre 8 et 12 kw à tous les coups non tu
en as marre quoi tu fais un tel avec td
toi tu allais fait un double une fois
quoi un doubleur il rejoue quoi mais bon
c'est un double donc je rejoue mais oui
c'est dur un bon football sis ou mi6
paraît pas du coup je suis peut-être
pour icare où je fais comme l'a dit hier
je retourne ma veste en pied s'ils
jouent mieux tu arrives de gagner quoi
carl johnson
peut-être que furent des échecs ses
limites sur internet
ouais je sais pas ou alors peut-être que
le futur d'internet c'est le futur défi
sur internet si les échecs alors qu'un
sané yayi comprends pas dit que tu es
parti donc c'est nul mais que le qui
jouent des bee gees
bah en fait j'aimerais bien que ça
évolue loin pour moi plus rapide alors
pas forcément faire que des blitz
mais les partis déjà un premier pas très
une heure trente plus 30 secondes ça
donne vraiment la crédence et de deux
temps que le format est comme ça et que
tu a le talent pour devenir champion du
monde battu d'apprendre ta chance c'est
tout c'est que tu vas a gâché son
potentiel qui va gâcher son talent est
dommage que ces rares les gens qui
prétendent être champion du monde en
fait n'importe quelle discipline
mais peut-être que les mecs juste un
athée de 5 par génération 10 max si tu
étais un un bain prends ta chance mais
peut-être que le mec a juste envie
d'être heureux en fait peut-être que
certains mettent parfois même fait il
veut juste que je te parle de ce qu'ils
devraient faire si si si voilà s'il veut
obtenir le titre est donc séparée mais
après alors internet que je viens chez
moi y'a pas d'âme trois hommes c'est ça
qu'elle y prendre ses cinquièmes s'agit
bien sûr de huit matchs peut-être non
mais je leur parlais ce que c'est mieux
devient champion du monde comme
wilkinson est complètement fou et ce
qu'il vaut mieux être un peu moins fort
et très heureux de tout c'est une ration
c'est mieux très heureuse et attend il
donne des six cas des silhouettes
humaines jamais rien fait ne s'est pas
battu le dommage oui mais bon j'étais
3ème rima situer non mais c'est pour ça
qu'il s'agit là d'un vestige de 3,5
ça ressemble pas grand chose que je suis
en train de proposer des pots venez
passer un bon exemple du super génial
mais pau c'est un peu le même style
j'aurais pu être champion du monde
peut-être on sait pas mais il n'a pas
réalisé son talent à fond mais mans
autre côté il est très heureux de tout
donc ma défaite en tant que en fait je
suis pas leur donner du pain je fais un
coach de vie je parle juste niveau
chacun après moi je pense le but dans la
vie c'est juste d'essayer d'être heureux
peu importe ce que tu fais ici tant
mieux tu as réussi ta vie
ouais mais du coup on donc mais en gros
si je m'occupe pas de ce mec est que
l'ambition je pense que ça va ça veut
dire et je te dernier pas de jouer tout
le temps en cours à fin mai tell me toi
quoi
si tu fais une arena par semaine voilà
c'est déjà bien mais peut-être qu'avec
te dis je suis très heureux de faire ça
enfin tu as enfin qui se réfère ben je
m'entraîne plus vous ne voyez pas ça que
tu peux tu peux faire comme un genre oui
mais tu peux fondamentalement n'y a pas
là mais ce soir là de plein de trucs
la dernière fois c'est comme une double
attaque mais cela c'est quand même le
fou a dit là il a raté d'un f3 et quoi
dégoûter là c'est génial même kevin
l'avez vu enfin ça le fait marrer ça ils
rigolent de partout c'est génial mais le
truc c'est que je n'aime pas capté
pourquoi comprendre que c'était comme en
photo je sais pas mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que la france a gagné une pièce je
vois la vie sur la tête qui faisait pas
fait
bon mais il est trop fort knocked up ne
sert à rien i'm ok devrait y avoir un
arrêt qui tient au trop large
voilà un chaos quoi battre la n va la
gagner celle-là ça sent bon les bonnes
et 15 secondes et puis la position non
c'est évident quand même même fipd c'est
pas si grave enfin mais bon donc trop
dur et c'est sa pire cas dans sanaa
non mais c'est le pire long du match
fourni et après on va passer en trois
minutes dont 25 du lot pauvres et les
voies n'ont pas de chance non et c'est
génial parce qu'en plus sénac acquis car
d'abord ce rêve je comprends pas comment
ça se faire quoi non mais il est trop
fort sur internet mais plus mais en vrai
pourquoi ni la joie des jeunes au nombre
de 800 cas de shu manque peut-être il va
me en données cvs de moins est ce
possible
il ya peut-être saint pierre il faut
aussi qu'il n'a pas pas à jouer les
championnats du monde de glisse quand il
était à son poste et qu'après quand il a
joué la joue en même temps que magnus et
magnus quand même plus fort que lui
non mais mac os x 30 ans tu as un mec
qui arrive à se faufile entre les
gouttes et vendent tout cas gagné une
fois où vichy la stella rapide l'année
dernière n'est pas ta des gars c'est pas
le meilleur joueur objectivement de
blitz au monde vivant de choc mais juste
il me dit dangereux ici dans un bon jour
il y arriver sans rapide n'arriveront
sur la sat 1 minute
non mais ils vendent succès initial oui
moi devons tous comprendre qu'il est
temps d'essayer pour 2,5 et tu faire une
place mais ok ça il va récupérer son
pion il va faire nul va perdre du coup
il ya deux secondes on sait juste chiant
payer faire voir à 4,5
il y avait un truc mais bon on va faire
ça il va faire redescendre lentement
sentir quand je les tours on recadre
soir c'était trop tard tu me fais
tourner deux
fait tourner 2 mai à faire à ses 600 ça
si c'est un tour de chauffe avait
simplement un choix que le faire tomber
pas de chance tesfran pions pour prendre
à prendre enlevée samedi est bon on peut
c'est d'amener le fou par là où
carrefour des deux rois bush
bush
bah alors qu'elle valent en achat oui je
sais pas ce que viennet sets gagnants ça
sent le fouillent wenger way l'écurie
écuries tout cas tous d'accord mais
maintenant il faut b2c d'un point à
chaque fois trois méchants private a été
complètement écuries pas ça le fait
marrer place et il se dit oui j'ai fait
55 / puzzle au rush mais je ne vois pas
d'âme f3 abondamment bon allez voir que
damon gagné une partie quoi vous croyez
le ou non mais c'est chiant vous n'êtes
que vous leur tapez va les voir gagner
une partie ça se paye une fronde
yoann lui signé le 3 défaites ces
convois quoi quand il peut s'en sortir
la ménaka il est tellement facile c'est
ça qui est impressionnant c'est que là
il est vraiment pas 100% non mepha
votants je suis le premier à critiquer
naka et être contre caen autant quand je
vois jouer comme ça c'est quand même
fort non mais chaque feuille est
impressionnant dans les speechs pas dire
je capte pas tout cas ce que genre un
maximum en il est bien qu il la fois
contre mais je pense qu'ils ont le même
style jusqu'à d'un cahier plus fort en
bits fait je demande à voir un échiquier
[Musique]
solar prometteur ça pour le moment ou
non
donc on le défend 2004 cette fois qui
parcourt alors qu'avec ce qu il veut
essayer de faire du cavalier g4 prend un
but de matt
un ok bon ok peut-être on va faire
simple ce n'était pas l'objectif
ok mais connaissait pas c'est sûr il n'a
pas trop la naloxone voyez dans le thème
comme dans l'arène du shopping sur le
thème c'est génial il ya google chrome
des quatre fers belges à reprendre et je
te 5 complète mais j'ai compris bah il
connaît
s'ils gèrent en fait tu ne te réponds
pas tu juste qu'il connaît mal non non
vraiment on aurait peut-être fait
qu'elle faisait 4 quand même le sol
c'est quand même qualifié quatre camps
mais je suis fou prend des huit futur
proche d'eux tu fais prise exception
français trois échecs d'objets de faire
tous rêvent de il fait fou prend acte de
ce problème de l'échec féroé fine c'est
tourache en échec il te bouffe la dame
et après et encaisse encore une pièce
quoi montrer de josée catalo questionne
comme nous le 5 et 4 francs des huit
enfants en âge de pions français 3,6
la caisse qui les forme à cannes mais
contre maxime il avait vraiment été
insupportable un parc d'être que toufik
et les trois mêmes écarts et les f3 mais
peut-être il faut peut-être après
cavaliers
imagine le niveau de magnus quand même
genre maca défonce tout le monde mais
genre hier dans ceux de la réflexion
genre saut il s'était pris +18 par
magnus
c'est dire que en fait mais fait un saut
il ay +13 à duda et ils feront 18 faf
s'est dit choqué
je crois que tant internet en pls ah bon
tu m'entends la houppe
la chanteur et non mais c'est comme çà
pour çà va maquiller va faire piéger car
je pense au caissier truc avec tout
reprend h de damages suite ça regardez
mais non je crois pas nouveau - hautmont
conclure à la volée très vite il trouve
sur le dos et sur donc la dame y
attaquer ses cavaliers trois là par
exemple les gens dans l'utah non mais
déjà battus pour ça quand je gagne était
pas mal surtout des fondatrices de
taille juste dame g8 tu pars tu es
damage cette année je pensais
franchement des prochains car c'est
finir non mais fallait il ya d'autres
proposent il n'a pas besoin de votre
soutien
monsieur juste choix vos amis joue mieux
je pense faut qu'on fasse comme la non
quand un mec est vraiment beaucoup plus
forte en kikwete et pour le plus fort
tétreault t'es trop fort par rapport à
l'autre l'autre est trop nul
tant pis quoi toi tu venir tu mérites ne
mérite plus notre soutien
enfin ailleurs dommage pour un regard
enfin tu n'as qu'à y est plus fort il
n'est pas assez fort il perd tout cas
peut-être d'un match 7
lynché sf6 moment mais on va prendre le
truc en c4 déjà où diable rouge et 4 je
sais pas où j'ai cas c'est pas bête
n'était at on seulement un truc emprise
en fait peut-être france et 4 c'est bien
en fait ouais bah je ne comprenais pas
ce qu'est ce qui vous prend ce qu'est
france 4 cavaliers
ces dames j'ai tout ce qui arrive si ça
te force à mettre la dame en fuite à
plus de
on peut te la donner enfin d'autres mais
c'est pas faux non je sais pas décemment
pas mal de management il a pris en
oeuvre qu'elle et ses savants voilà
raconte alors ils vont tuer lmnp et
dames et fit dame g3 ça peut être
choquant même dans ce cas suède est mal
parti merci non non pour cent mécontents
bah alors est-ce qu'il peut jouer qui
est des deux tablettes et rhodes et
pourrait vite en f1
et puis tu fais jamais bon et chacun
fait un peu mais réfute walf tv quand
j'ai une idée fouache 6 fait ouais
exactement ça sinon ce serait parfait
pas de chance mais bon c'est dan c8 ces
dames c'est 8 ah c'est beau ça très beau
c'est beau c'est beau c'est beau tracé
bossa et sur qui les prend g8 qui a
touché qu'un jeu 4 1 infligé quatre
étaient deux fois 6
bon ok on aime et on prend tout reprend
et du bouffey dans la nature attends là
matériellement tendu où tu as quand même
deux pièces de labeur et à des plus bas
de 4 600 tas de pièces net
je crois que ça va pas trop pour les
blancs ok là d'annoncer la nageuse lui
et on imagine eyes sur rage et de tact
et de trois échecs à michel-ange du club
photo de nuit ils vont passer dans une
pièce donne le droit valbuena lui y est
elle est là il peut faire des jacquet et
des deux sacrifiant h3 récupère en f1 et
regrouperont le cinquième jeu mais il
peut faire une razzia des pions quoi à
lima il peut aussi peut-être faire car a
lieu de trois je penche sur les cahiers
des deux est prise à froid prises afin
prise aux cinq ans faire gaffe futur
être un peu dangereux de médecins
d'autres admirent la même cinq magasins
tu es en plus peut-être raison
france 3 tours à la suite du contrôle
bien trélat taden de baryton roi tout
barre des 25 c bien je pensais mer mais
bon pour qu'elle ait donné pas mal en
fait je payais 2e g 2e jeu 3 rue fait un
top 5
ou bien on prend ces trois heures mais
prend donc tranquille pathé tous les
risques mais après peut-être qu'on peut
essayer d'être d'optimiser votre grille
réfléchit donc il va nous trouver une
veine où trouver le truc barrière est
combien de temps il reste il reste et
restera encore une partie après ça là en
cinq minutes normalement google car
c'est vraiment plus fort que notre
langue le web et il est plus fort on va
disputer la finale les deux dernières
saisons et ya pas eu de match
bah ouais enfin après ça il n'y avait
pas trente personnes en fait presque
penser que le seul qui a plus ou moins
qui aurait pu mettre en danger carlson
c'était gris tchouk voilà même mis non
mais c'est quoi tous que c'est un bon
joueur nom n'étant plus forts en bulles
est c'est le seul qui a tenu je crois
qu'il est à - 2 avant le début du bullet
ou moins quoi mais bien qu'après fort
que great choc en un contre un tu as et
un peu marrant comme truc j'en ai un
cabas great choughri choo c'est le seul
peut-être qu'il ya là le truc c'est que
dacca fois personnes servant son anti sa
kryptonite
mais son alter ego devant mon style pour
pour le battre d'ailleurs c'est pas pour
rien qu'il est un score de ouf
mais il a géré par duke compris dans
d'ailleurs en lente je crois qu'il a
perdu une finalement chaque évidemment
il avait perdu une chez +1 bilbao
tiens me sentais si peu et c'est un peu
comme shearer pour kasparov à l'époque
des fois tu as des chats noirs des bêtes
noires
pas des chats aussi implique une baisse
des achats fighter une bête ou
renversement bogey et robinho je crois
qu'il peut tout faire même jeu des trois
pions prend qui va faire genre fougue et
si c'est ça qui s'adapte partout tu as
tu des six tours à quatre tours à 94,15
tient bien droit qu'à trois des sept
tours h4 bon bah quoi faire quoi
c'est perdu
c'est fini en plus les pions blancs
c'est horrible il se fond complètement
maîtrisé par le cavaliere l'attaqué est
carré lieu de trois c'est horrible ce
tournoi c'est très dur mais alors plus
qu il était d'envoyer kouame francs le
contre-feu à chaque fois mais à ménaka
il ferme pas quoi faire et il est là
j'aime attaquer tient d'autres donnent
des pièces je bouffe je défends sa
péniche des changes
voilà donc il a joué à street clip 6
sata quand même pas grand monde qui est
capable de prendre les pièces et je suis
même pas sûr que carl scène ils
réussissent à jouer comme ça contre les
vannes on me voit autrement maintenant
prendre vraiment un jeu rapide plus
pratique du tri sera en attendant la
finale sans trop de réfléchir je sais
pas oui non mais sûrement mais je veux
dire par là que qui peut s'asseoir à la
table
de là à dire aussi bien des pièces que
toi ouais parce que ce qu'il est en
train de faire et les pièces qui est en
train de manger de partout c'est
impressionnant à tangi si c'est parti
comme ça jusqu'à l'effroi mg6 se donner
envie peut il restait trois dames des
six je connais parlement sur rien de
plus
la demande est bon et son âme ses cinq
pas mal aussi donc on joue sur le
clouage et le 5 % ne peut pas bouger
parce qu'elle est dommage 5 derrière et
donc éventuellement vous atteindrez jar
jar fouet 3 tu fais quoi être fier d'ars
à 5 bas je pensais boucherie de 30 ou
des deux pins mais 33 de jeu c'était un
coup non ah mais elle gère pas je parle
de mévente et que j'ai six mois un thème
j'ai six semaines mais j'étais en train
de manière floue et 3 400 bons coups que
je sais pas je sais pas ce n'est pas sa
position où je peux pas trop lâché
l'info je me questionne maintenant g6 il
fait qu'ali prend j'imaginais dames 5
c'est joli ça et donc c'est un problème
mais dieu que les noirs comment tu
développes assez grand roque tf cette
fleur je pense
tadam label encore perdre des temps
c'est peut être dangereux pour les voilà
en fait j'ai dit la dame elle a juste
évoqué à la casse b2 encore mais tu veux
toujours bien sûr on fait tous rêver en
fait menaces quand même grave de se
faire enfermer sans fausse vraie vie tu
vas prendre b2 donc souveraineté devrais
je pense les voiliers de fer tour c1 et
faire damas trois parties à tout pour
partir loin c'était une chanson 213 tu
connais non
tonton du bled je connais ce way
peut-être ou peut-être rim'k avec un
featuring ces problèmes plutôt rime
qu'avec un featuring que 113 et ceux qui
parce que demain selon parce que demain
c'est loin cr yam ses dernières chansons
de l'album l'école du micro d'argent
blunt et boston
ouais c'est peut être le meilleur album
de rap français
fantasque et us c'est quoi dr dre domine
un cépage connais moi rap us sûr et
moins capable de m'exprimer mais ouais
prenez 2001 mais je sais pas peut-être
les barrages eh bien tu pas que je sais
qu'il ya plein de gens qui
qui me critiquent pour eminem est
minable on adore mais non mais très bien
surtout les deux premiers albums sim
chez jmp marshall mathers lp mais non
mais très très bien et même très très
bien mais j'aime bien tout upac il a
pris sa retraite un peu minable où je
fais des trucs poursuit par l'argent et
j'ai complètement de la merde tout temps
c'est génial et du coup c'est en fait
c'est le problème c'est qu'il faut
partir comme gary le problème c'est que
tu as été une légende mais si tu pars
pas quand il faut tu vois ça te des les
gens disent même tes albums de légende
vous faites les légendes elle par toto
tu as dre il est parti quoi faire lui
les parties de la musique je fais
freddie mercury tu as un mec tu sais
plus à quoi bon vouloir bien d'autres
encore mais bon je suis une légende des
insulaires cif
je pense dans plein de choses pour
devenir une légende il faut quand même
partir assez tôt quoi que ce soit
volontairement pas si tu restes tu
restes tu restes tu restes tu deviens
l'ombre de toi même à force à jordan à 9
mais là mais bon tu es revenu n'est fait
non mais c'est vrai mais bon eminem trop
déçu parce qu'il fait maintenant même si
j'adore t il fait beau pays chantent de
ses plumes fait du commercial maintien
tupac aussi partis tôt tu vas du coup
j'ai pâture est sûre tu restes sur son
image à son apogée tu vois
tu as envie de dernier album d'eminem
est pas mal malgré les mauvaises album
avant moi j'ai complètement lâché en
fait du coup déconvenue aujourd'hui tu
veux te dit ça on est suspendue six ans
je viens ici ça ouais après tu pars en
savoie ils sont deux premières pages de
la première page je peux savoir que
après laon n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
à la chaîne bat angers 2e dans mon jour
ok les gens du ku'damm g3 alors je vais
me bloquer le sont donc dame g3 est ok
je jouais là il veut jouer la finale
donc sur dame prend puis on prend qui
les prend à eux quatre banques et prend
le cas tout reprend 1,4 et tours 17
quelque chose comme ça bah c'est ce qui
va jouer c'est ce qui va être jouée à
moins qu'ils prennent pas en quatre il
faut que je te prendre une carte peut
faire tourner cette direct je suis de
retour
il faut faire prendre quatre tournées
c'est éventuellement autour d un
tournant pas mal il prend une nouvelle
colonne ouverte et va essayer d'aller là
bas sur la social non mais ça est assez
ya cette histoire est comme ça surtout
ses quatre tours b 7 pour ses 8 il aura
tout repenser cette en france s est
tourné huit matchs avec ses actifs lui
dream du coup et bien tu vas être celle
là on s'est un peu dangereux que ça
donne je pars tout confirmé l'avancé
deux ça va enfin il ya sûrement pas
gagné mais bien les pendants jeu tour de
satan pour ces huit tours d'essai 3,8
prise priest reprend ses 4 reste avec un
fond plus et après ils placent la tour
en a4 entre les deux pions autour des
tronches bise à la tour 17 tours 7
si vous avez toujours ça de pris on a du
mal à se détacher des f2 et surtout b8
il fera à tour b3 pour se remettre la
structure bien y avoir tout retourné 7 c
sur nous tous vos trois tours 17
mais y'aura tours 8 brice prise c'est
cet été pour un peu faire le truc et
tour à quatre mains mais ça va être dur
à tenir c'est là pour dacca théâtre brut
une logique blain bon je veux apprendre
mais il peut faire tourner en russie et
surtour ces deux tours france et cette
affaire j'ai quelque chose pour ce mythe
[Musique]
qu'est tour 8 forcé ouais mais peut-être
que la fête s'est vu transposition dans
ce site hors france est qu'ils arrivent
et la deuxième tour qui se nouent 60e
c'est toujours pénible qui s'annonce de
partout côté n'a qu'à mon tour e sata 6g
que la tour 6e j'ai cinq tours à f4 et
très troisième était peut-être peut-être
g5 maintenant haye a pris après c'est
pour ça que le petit les garder un peu
l'impression de croire en place jusqu'à
la tour à 4 je crois qu'il n'a pas fait
j'ai ça encore trois capos d'affaires
pour ces sept on prend 1,6 à 3 2 face à
l' il peut la voir depuis tout à l'heure
de finale mais t'es pas bien ténu à la
torche des cinq continents
il faut ici
quatre des fans de kery james aussi chez
page semble ouvrage le g5 et non mais là
c'est grâce à ses succès mais je pense
le pianiste en équipe de france c'est le
cas de figure où tu cours avec ton roi
sur le sol dame
et comme les blancs s'étaient pas trois
pions comme classique ligne
il s'est un peu doublé peut-être peu
plus facilement un jeu là pour contrer
pion à 1 dans ce cas tu essayais madame
si peu de choses
du coup me pose
ouais ouais normalement après cela il ya
une pause à vérifier quand même mais
normalement à moins nouvelles règles
mais cette histoire bien défendre c'est
le truc hyper important déchet c'est
logique vu que le jeu est
fondamentalement nul
en fait je pense que s'il était
fondamentalement un jeu gagnant ce
serait linverse sacilor si
fondamentalement des blancs gagner
j'imagine que bien attaquer ce serait
plus important et surtout pas croire
surtout parole j'écris je peux pas trop
me fasse prendre là tout ranger 4 mai
qui est peut-être trois proches 4 ici
ouais ouais ça sans rien faire f 5
ok on apprend ici c'est très lourd on m
l'orangé un phare à 10 ans passe il
signale y réfléchir cfaf même où on n'a
pas le temps de réfléchir faire mieux
non mais je suis je pour réfléchir je
trouve ça ils devraient jacques 5
secondes dans la pendule ou là pas mal
quand même
ok donc mini-pause jeunesse de seconde
vas-y vas-y fille bien pas tout de suite
ça j'en profite pour dire à tout le
monde de s'abonner à la chaîne parce
qu'il faut s'abonner il faut s'abonner
les tontons la chaîne chez ce point
quand même très très important demain
soir 21h on aura la grande finale la
finale du speech s avec pas probablement
n'a qu'à contrôler ouest et sont donc un
duel américano américain où son %
américain où je sois qu'on voulait dire
on vous dit que vous voulez enfin un
duel qui sera sous le signe de la
bannière étoilée j'ai envie de dire il y
aura des étoiles de partout la manière
sera étoiles et même heure dans 21h21
heures demain soir demain soir un petit
peu plus tard en prime time j'ai envie
de dire
un viking et c'est vrai que c'est
fondamentalement nul il n'y a pas de
preuves scientifiques mais on le sait si
tu vas fort en revue les parties
d'ordinateurs les parties parfaites et
vu toutes les positions qui nous
paraissaient perdante et qui sont
défendables
c'est pas prouvée mais tu as un joueur
de consortiums qui te dit que fatou les
grands mais ce disque c'est nul en gros
les échecs son fondateur
fondamentalement nul mais après c'est
pas grave en soi c'est c'est juste une
heure
c'est juste une une chose à savoir quoi
enfin c'est comme ça mais pourquoi pas
que je m'arrête autant lui que ce soit
nulle fin je me crois j'y tant mieux
mais voilà c'est nul c'est nul c'est
sympa ça pose pas problème
mais du coup ça c'est sûrement pour ça
que c'est plus facile de défendre aux
échecs
ça permet d'avoir un style plus défensif
de l'état se permet de de tenir parce
qu'un truc est fondamentalement nul et
quand le mec tu attaques tu peux
contre-attaqué comme fondamentalement tt
défensif et tu tu fais là nul et il joue
que sur les erreurs et si tu réussis à
parfaitement défends tu perdras jamais
en gros avantage des blancs ne suffit
pas
du jus qu'il est pourtant sûr les
parents adorent d'iliad et surtout à
paris à des parties décident oui mais
souvent sur l'étang adorni il force d
ouverture c'est pour ça que parfois tu
te retrouves avec des ordis qui joue des
gros bouts d ouverture spéciale
c'est pour éviter qu'il y ait trop de
nuls ils les forcent à jouer d ouverture
où il peut se passer des choses ou pas
d'ailleurs mais tu peux être tirés au
hasard des stocks fiche quand il aura
les blancs il est plus fort et il fera
nul avec la grob et puis l'autre qui est
moins fort avec les noirs ben quand il
jouera la grotte qui perdra et pour les
caméras je vais recadrer si besoin mais
ils font ce truc dans les tours
d'ordinateurs avec les ouvertures
forcées
pas pour le match alpha 0 stockfisch non
pour le feu hadj alpha 0 stockfisch il
n'y avait pas ça mais malgré tout il ya
plus deux nuls que deux victoires malgré
la domination de alpha 0 qui était a
priori plus fort que stockfisch il ya
quand même eu plus de nuls que deux
victoires l'alto pair avec la grogne m
c'est ça arrive de perdre avec la grotte
mais bon fins c'est dommage mais c'est
pas de chance de perdre avec la grave
mais ça peut arriver
non pas au meilleur mais ça peut arriver
ça peut arriver de perdre avec la grande
dur dur la grob dur dur de gros b enfin
qu'ils ont forcé des ouvertures mais n'y
a pas eu d'ouverture gerin bizarrement
dans les partis qui ont été gagnés que
j'ai vu a pas eu d'ouverture bizarre
parce que j'ai 4 ans mais j'ai une
nouvelle expression un an j'ai dit que
l'aggraver le point g des échecs
j'ai trouvé cette nouvelle expression
hier soir peut-être j'ai déjà pensé mais
juge n'avait pas formulé où je m'en suis
plus rappelé j'ai peut-être dit
complètement fou dans un scream une fois
mais du coup je les formuler avec un
copain ya vous fab est de retour du
joueur sont de retour et je vais
recadrer les caméras ouais je vais
essayer de recadrer les caméras parce
que ça c'est des katas et on va d'abord
le jon savage on encadre oui il descend
de sa chaise
non non ça va il résisté prouve qu'il
existe c'est les caméras qui ont été des
cadres et donc je vais recadrer il ya
quelqu'un qui est parti
fac naka il est de nouveau là ok et
levon du neuf minutes je peux passer
si tu feras une partie de la partie de
naka de ning contrôle belle je crois pas
non c'est pour donner de noms je pense
pas il ya tellement de trucs qui sont
pas sortis tu vois des arénas des
machins en réserve mais là il y en a
tellement eu de vidéo tu vois que bouffe
peut-être que celle contre ding je sais
pas où ces partis qui se sont jouées
pendant le match champion du monde tu
vois pas en quoi c'est comme si ça
n'existait pas je suis fière
c'est très bizarre qui les détournent à
prendre fin du monde tout en s'y pique
échec du coup nakheel va refaire sa
formation forme de montagne qu eric
besson avec le pic saint loup un f4
peut-être mais les vents ils sentry 6
il sentait un peu d'air avec cette
ouverture goody tente de faire qui fait
quoi
c'est ce que tu ressens après ma route
et donc il a par contre dès fois je 4 ok
ok mais ch
donc ça peut être bien pour les noirs
on est d'accord du consensus qu'on est
pour nous un cabanon pas texto est ce
qu'il ya un consensus qu'on dit on non
en fait foi je peux pour lui mettre en
danger qui gagnent face à ces actes
étaient à peu près du dommage tu vois
qu'il ya déjà plus 4 après pratiquement
cela nous laisse pas là ça nous laisse
pas le aucun suspense n'a déjà bon avant
le match on n'avait pas trop de doutes
sur l'issue il donné combien les
pourcentages les ordi je sais pas j'ai
pas regardé pour le match de duda du cou
qui s'est encore trompé un d'ailleurs
puisqu'il donnait 12 à favoris et j'ai
pas regardé je vais jeter un oeil temps
je vais regarder s'est intéressée mans
cette année en plus des scores logiciels
des données qu'ils ont pourtant eu
toutes ses stats et even cette année
jade houdeïda j'avais compris il ne
m'est pas favoris gagner chaque fois le
feu robert tête il a eu un rush 1 ok
alors il y donnait à 80 % à 70 30
l'équation des bilans fait que c'est
génial il tenait un colloque est favori
n'a bloqué ni 70,36 de donner quatre et
demi quatre et demi en 5 5 il tiendrait
cinq et demi quatre et demi en 3 et 6 4
en bullet dans les couettes m'en fout en
fait ça va être sûrs que ça en fait il
est complètement nul cet algorithme
faits dont on l'encensé il tombait juste
par tous et que la chance vous êtes nuls
bon qui est mieux je ne sais pas mais
mais mais sa mise et when the way pour
la finale et tout change un peu discuté
avec ça on jouait sous il va se faire
défoncer tout tu vois les samedis
maintenant c'est pas si clair je suis
pas si c'est bien lui qui a trouvé pas
voir ce que va dire voilà
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça non
je pense qu'il va on sait bien les
racheter une option que je suis content
de me virer au bout d'une heure
automatiquement que j'étais inactif il
te propose une bonne question est ce que
tu toujours là mais dit oui je suis
toujours là et là je suis parti pour une
heure de plus sans pas mal quoi bein
demande oui il était quand même très
très bien élevé d'après me tutoie je
sais pas a écrit tu aimes écriture ouais
mais là tu as raison nous ils veulent
montrer ça va mais ni sa familiarité
avec toi at elle un dragon de komodo
quoi et a vu aussi que de chasse bong a
été intégré à access point commun
autrement ça manquait un peu porteuses
comme si l'histoire de deux parties live
et diffusion match est bon de façon
stable sur lequel je la regarde en
général ce n'est pas le plus beau mais
il est juste assez pratique
c'est peut-être plus efficace quand des
sur le téléphone il est bien en fait
saiful au jazz qui est bien aussi mais
de très bien fait ce bonbon donc bon
choix de tout chemin comme de france du
coup on envoyait des double six avec
chaises longues
oui c'est vrai que c'était le gros point
faible un poursuivre les parties en
direct c'était et après si jamais ils
veulent faire un truc ultime il re
design le truc mais ils vont le faire en
fait c'est prévu mais du coup qui a
accès via pièces comme maintenant il
faut quand même sur 62 sites dépend
indépendant normes anti avec session
cheska mais chez plus comment dans un
truc non plus enfin moi je fais des
check points comme cela chez van sant
fait et tu tombe dessus mais c'est très
intéressant qu'un truc
par contre ça aidera commando qui aurait
des double six temps peu plus quoi bon
j'ai dit à sam que je voulais absolument
un t-shirt komodo mais bon on fait avec
ouais j'ai compris que personne n'allait
me l'offrir moi j'aimerais qu'il allait
devoir acheter quoi je suis senti ça
c'est fort bien pas tout à fait cavalier
h3 sur tours d2 pour faire tourner car
trop peu d'hommes
ouais mais bon c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
des trois non je vais être obligée de me
lâcher le turc le commodo en fait et ils
menacent toujours un échec 3 f 2 bat
tours un vrai rêve de créer des
banquiers des trois ya pas parce qu'à
toi rang des français cette poule
j'avais pas vu à deux mois qu'est ce que
je me ferais des fonds stéphane
accueille tous les chip aux tournois de
mons n'arrivons il faut qu centré sur le
tas qui crachent je joue pas je suis à
fond dedans pour chercher la mairie va
perdre par contre maca le b767 du
tactique roche de folie non mais j'ai
été obligé d'acheter ce t-shirt j'ai
trop envie de la voir avec les 6 1 jeudi
mais peut-être si je retourne aux états
unis meilleurs que prévu
leur dire vous voyez le truc la codah un
peu été sympa il me l'envoyer ouais mais
bon ici je t'avais fils et non un vrai
réveil n'arrivons après leur truc qui
coûte et coûte 20 $
enfin gérard savard japon je vois rien
mon choc sont signés de mes propos
meilleur parent quant aux états dits du
coup bas trop joué à tahiti je vais
passer mes
mais la darpa quatre ans il te reprend
des 5 mai ce qui va y vas y vas y vas y
attend ouah qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ok mais ton franc et tour c'est cette
arrimé à ça mais du mont d'or et des
fonds qu'ils ont goûté à perte
non non il y aura dame achats n'ont rien
fait y a pas d'âme j'ai trois lions
qaïda auquel even qui gagne comme une
partie ça y est on est pourri car ou est
ce fini quoi il va se défoncer c'est
vrai y compris le on a compris envers ce
qu'on devait faire
non mais du coup je vais peut-être me
commander quand même un t-shirt komodo
enfin rouler dans l'espace personnel
maintenant je peux m'acheter un lien
pour les gens que tout le monde une
charte commune mais je comprends que ce
soit chez eux en cas de fraude expédié
truc en france mais dont koffi dit comme
je vais passer trois jours à los angeles
avant de la tahiti sur la suite
j'aimerais tant qu'à faire attention en
train de ce nom mais en fait ils sont
ils travaillent avec quand il s'appelle
avec ti avec titi ce prix où je sais
plus comment s'appelle donc c'est plus
un problème du tout en fait mans le ils
ont tout le truc d'envoi et tout mais
c'est où
attends attends je vais trouver je vais
envoyer aux gens pour qu'ils puissent le
voir bataillon ces deux cadeaux qui
l'acteur sa langue il est il à la 2d
rouge c'est ça fasse un truc qu'on voit
toujours
ouais on peut jouer conclusions
serviront banalisée on peut faire des
trucs non bah enfin tu t'en vois que des
double six copains tu es d'accord va
très dommage que je puisse pas analyser
avec eux je vois bien ben non mais tu
peux analyser les mecs c'est fait un
double 6 août sujet mais que non je
crois pas qu'ils puissent utiliser alors
attends c'est faux que je m quoi comodo
non ouais n'attend pas non je ne trouve
pas mais nous peur si mal pour les non
c'est finalement en train non mais il
s'est fait des plans doublé mais il
l'est les quatre fortes
bon sur magna ne veux pas parce que les
pions des six cd 6 tu vas pas les
toucher comme c'est avec les blancs et
donc les 900 places je ne vois pas même
sa gaffe avec les blancs ce que le fou
17 un jour n'était une passe ses 2 ou
des de 13,5
je sais pas bon ben on en reparlera plus
tard je trouve pas malheureusement battu
les vues ici si j'avais montré
d'ailleurs peut-être maintenant je
t'avais montré sur le site en voulait il
était super beau tu avais il était cousu
il était cousu dessus avec le commodo
qui auront un double 6 et qui tire la
langue
il oui je les trouve un hammam et le
lien dans le tchat
je vous montre ses sur amazon ce qu'on
voit bien dans la caméra on voit pas
très bien
ouais là on le voit bien à temps remonte
un peu le téléphone ouais mais c'était
sûr que c'est joli tee shirt beige et
ben je n'entretiens ce qu'ils hernan en
effet un double 6 et à la langue n'est
pas de double aussi c'est un spa lui
carl lang et un échiquier maintenant
loti faire doubler si ce n'est pas
combien coûte non s'il existe en version
jeunes en version up en version femme et
en couleurs il est noir mais cinq
couleurs peut être noir mais vie slate
bleu royal ou ou argent les détails
house et white 22 dollars 1,23 dollar
est ce que je te dis c'est pas très cher
puis ce fut pire c'est que je parle à
samedi way parler nos t-shirts pendant
les stream et où tu as été très très
chaud quoi bon là tu as du coup je suis
je suis sans parler tu vois je me dis
vont j'en parle à attend peut-être c'est
ça attends attends attends peut-être
peut-être j'ai trouvé que vous envoyez
pasqualetti chercheurs.com
non c'est pas je suis calme qu'hier par
le trouver ce truc cg en fait on
s'attache fois la partie quand c'est
fini on en est votre le t-shirt à cet
âge je crois que j'ai trouvé la boutique
maintenant faite à tous les petits
châteaux il croit la raie manta donne
les bonnes non mais moi ils croient
alors attends toi c'est un vrai t-shirt
komodo mais c'est pas le commando monté
car l'autre tu as trouvé faut que je
trouve un mandat très clair c'est le
sait le commodo engine quoi je vais vous
trouvez tu veux dire un truc sur la
partie mais là je suis fut mal
comprendre attendant c'est à dire la
partie ça tourne un peu en rond mais
hargne ont pas mal mais sûrement sa être
juste nul les blancs un très mauvais fou
mais qui permet de tenir les pions si
besoin ne se prennent pas fou des trois
forêts fin pour perdre des pions de loin
et puis en b3 bien tenu mais ouais
toujours quand même plus amère pour les
marges sur la position mais je vois pas
de deux manières crevasse maintenant
c'est fantastique quand tu vas en
tournoi fut un flipper tout le monde tu
mets ton t-shirt comotto quoi vous à
versailles lance huard il vole comme ou
d'en face ouais non plus j'ai dit à sam
qu'il était beau ouais ok attend et on
alla alors là attendez tire la langue
mais il sait pas le double 6 mais bon il
est pas mal quand même temps j'en ai
déjà un premier temps mais déjà un
premier dans le chatt auquel est nulle
et un nul bien logique il est déjà pas
il est déjà pas mal hein même quand si
l'on va pas le double sens franchement
il a la gueule
et du coup je peux la renvoyer une
demandé de leur dire faites spécialement
pour nous qu'il envoie le doublé 6 quoi
bein triple six ans et ils gueulent boom
une petite bulle serait génial d'écrire
en direct quand le match est pas encore
rien qu'à lui think au temple un
commentaire du truck & haas can you make
de komodo shirt loose de de beule 6 dice
fin tu as we don't understand allégeant
distiller tu as des gens qui sont
contents eux ne comprennent pas
l'intérêt donnera un petit charte ouais
bah sinon général c'est par ce biais
justement vous avez d'abord francs du
coup est ce que tu peux en croit la
remonte à la non mais bon écoute ce très
beau ça serait beau mais s'estime être
le tee shirt comme aux us si je gagnais
géant au bout d'un moment il est bien
commenté mme bourgeois pas mais on sait
pas on ne sait pas il doit son casque et
où ménaka il en petite chemise à
carreaux borniche mais elle est bien
cette position enfin avec les noirs
je vous au golf il des parties leeuwen
et il maîtrise de mieux en mieux le
dragon donnacona cabécou elles
maîtriseront ça ressemble beaucoup aux
pinces et levante qui touche de la
partie d'avant
oui ça veut dire que j'ai rédigé un son
qui gaffe - quoi il non mais c'est
bizarre qu'il affectionne gaffe c'est
une entrée à droite la transforme et
rating et n'importe où mais tient moins
à rogner une violation sébastien je
crois qu'il habite à san sebastian je
pense aussi
après ce qu'il est là-bas pendant pour
le moment on sait pas mais ils habitent
là-bas c'est sûr pas sûr je pense aussi
on a les infos voilà alors bye coûte
juste bon pour moi ça me semble pas mal
tu rentres pas mal pour les noirs date
et sarrois h7 si on prend un f5 pour
tout envoyer me attias mais je trouve
pas mal il pressent que les blancs j'ai
pas trop le port des bonbons peut-être
virer la dame fabre et 4 peut-être ces
cinq un jour de cinq ans et là bas et
des puisque des cinq semaines calmes a
cassé sa pipe et randy caillou ici c'est
plus fort que le foot est roi chez ben
là je trouve bien sa tête un peu plus de
faire tout récente plainte au troc h 4
kf4 aussi bon ça va arriver tout à fait
ça il me rappelle un pull cavaliers
detroit dans les structures ou 15 bat
gers ici vit très bien en verve
silhouette vu notifier les colis de
personnes n'ont pas là dans une des
vidéos
oui les cavaliers installé sur f4 machin
qu'est des 3,2 à carlsbad
je sais qui sur ces cribles enfin la
carte pdci ceux des noirs mais il aime
bien kahn prend des tout ça il est très
heureux de sa mère il a d'ailleurs mis
en face avec laurent il a convaincu le
rendrai aussi bon mais sûrement pas pour
penser ça presque tour des seins c'est
votre match d'après tour un prêt à taux
plein ou 2.371 priori non je n'ai de
marché donc ne veut pas en reniant qui
assez fine action pour entrer sur le
terrain avec sa tour mais un petit
trophée ça sert à rien c'est la reculade
alain
il peut-être pour prendre des doses d'un
produit autour des 8 nous demandent ce
pacte pas claire parce que pandémie
d'hommes prendre 3-0 2006 hadji 5,5
mieux cela soit en gmf 2etour des 8 et
maintenant il reprend un clown des et
l'autre plan possible c'est juste faire
jusqu'à 4h 3 mais bon tour du très bien
joué très logique
on aimerait carte orange est importante
au cours des 2 donc quoi faire avec les
blancs quand en plus souvent autour des
1 qui forcent tour et un pour faire
tourner mais bon ils font affaire tour
de taille cela plutôt faire c'est qu'à
ses 80 très pénible ces quatre tours
détroit le classique
après tu peux calculer essayer de
trouver un truc très fort c'est le sien
mais le prix est peut-être une prime
autour des 4 je paie mon étage quatre
maintenant c'est par la culture h3 pré
tour d un tas plutôt rien pour défendre
s'y attend entouré d'amis et de m donc
ça c'est pénible avance de tous les
côtés le rappelons est beaucoup plus
faible et un environnement
c'est trop de soucis beaucoup de soucis
la bombe à des tarifs réduits à tenter
la sillage trois tours j'ai 2 h 3 tous
heureusement que ma mère je croyais à
tour f2 encore l'ours et 6
c'est un exemple c'est malin le vétéran
1 35 m de centres sociaux
je suis pas sûr qu'il ait fait truc le
plus simple du jeu puis on sait si c'est
mal placé celui là vb6 et d'orge et
d'eau à tout moment et tu gagnes est
juste le final d'options ouais bah il y
aurait faire du coup pays si ce fait est
un maïs qui en a ou slip et vous assiste
juste vous alors que vous appartient pas
tros position sous ces trois armes à
apporter on l'a entendu tellement de
fois hier avec vlad
oui ce prix est mauvais parce qu'il
n'appartient pas à cette position tu
n'as aucune culture
non mais là c'est sûrement son mot
sleeps il a raté un truc et c'est comme
ça mais ça tu te bloque pour expliquer
simplement jean tavé un 3 contre 2 tout
est bloqué ils étaient trois pions
valent pas mieux que de blancs tu peux
battre abc si tu peux pas faire ces cinq
dont tu te crées pas de pions basse et
si tu viens perec 3 du coup le royaume
occupe de loin
donc ça c'est le souci après bon vu que
renault n'a pu que deux secondes à la
pendue nam et madame j'ai trois échecs
mais je pense pas qu'il y ait de zahia
pas deux exemples mais avantage des
spasmes et ça suffit peut-être pas parce
qu'il prend le curage 3 parce que royak
4,3 m 2 y aura jamais de zouk sanglante
a qu'une case du retour de drogue demain
un truc avec l'appui un quinze jours on
prend re 3g ça c'est sûr maintenant il
parle the stone age quoi mais c'est dur
à jouer avec deux secondes
painchaud peut vraiment d'entreprise
chez soi à 6,1 kg tombera demain ce sera
3 pendant que ça pourrions donc va
arriver et il a tenu bon maintenant soit
juste tenir là pour nous c'est génial
que depuis qu'on est pour qourna cas
c'est fini c'est lui qui se fait
arnaquer mais ceci c'est sûrement vos
slips je pense pas
fringe à sétif obligé de faire un aussi
il va peut-être même la perdre
one on me l'a dit c'est de gagner mais
bon ça qui va reprend 1,5 à un moment
est ce que maintenant on passait d'un
médecin qui a son idée car oppose nul
acquis mais mais mais je suis d'accord
aronian faut qu'ils la jouent bien et
d'appréhender cet échec peut être mais
bon tu perdais l'option il va tomber en
fait bon ok oui pour sa chance dont il
s'était finie s'ils gagnent un peu
énorme et adam est vrai mais c'est pas
ce qu'il fait il va le gagner deux pions
17 ben ça autrement que je n'en a pas
six s'ils gagnent 17 et qui gagna si ces
trésors un remplaçant mais c'est pas mal
je dois perdre la connaît c'est bien
joué hier james qui va le faire tomber
il ne peut pas échanger dans la
conception a pris fuite dames et chaque
pas de chance je bats il a fait parce
qu'il savait que l'autre il avait prévu
autre chose parce que c'était pas
possible à 5 904 6 autres machins enfin
on fait fi de damas quand même à vendre
ouais mais sur l'échec 3b droit edd ha
même si c'était fini mais le truc c'est
qu'il a joué au bluff bon match est fini
quoi tu tu ne peux pas prendre du coup
tu après mouvement un autre coup et
quand on te prends tu es très surpris
quoi très bien joué de la part de dacca
d'après les intrus pour un miroir je
pensais que ça permet juste
une très grosse victoire bon attention
n'était pas très inquiet pour lui mais
bon là ça stoppe toute velléité de
retour
du coup ils appellent flag murat dans le
chatt duchess comme non mais bon on a
juste un problème le temps et puis y'a
pas la partie qui la gaine c'est mérité
de l'inité gagnant est là sur mon fils
m'a aussi par contre si ailleurs s'il
paye merci curieux mais il a proposé lui
non plus oui la toile letombe l'on tombe
tu vas pas abandonner pour le plaisir
fantastic m
koné baca j'aime bien s'imposer sûrement
avec les plans la meilleure structure
père de fou et les espaces allaient
droit
je pensais juste beaucoup mieux nous
sommes français de tout format dat en c1
donc au delà de son design savions que
jusqu'à mais c'est génial flag murat
comme comme son flegme ira au moc très
content quoi ouais c'est une ak murat
assez fine murat les amis il a perdu
contre un nul en quatre sets par à jouer
mais bon ça va ça ça va pas bien à toi
peut-être te faire tourasse comme votre
poisson les oeufs et d'imbécile en fout
ok du coup peut-être pris ce prix sous
ces cinq échecs ils échangent sur
admettra latour ans et 8 et peut-être
mais bon c'est bien lui ouais ok mithra
v5 est bon non mais je suis d'accord
mais bon peut-être qui change beaucoup
pas des fauves les six attentats
c'est de ces deux ce que le truc qui
veulent donc si c'est un ours d henri iv
où il va jouer la finale en fait fondée
d'abord tiré pendant toutes ces dames
des deux tours d un nom il ya quatre
sites au but hier dame b 4 g/t changé
mais toujours sa septième mais vous qui
mettez un problème n'était tour f2b pu
repartir je peux annoncer 8 ou quelque
part vous inquiétez d'apprentis est bien
vite à manquer et 17 ans fait tailler
des parts ici ce qui a valu à ses tarifs
6 août à tv5 ou un truc qui serait un
plus avec dame b6 foot judo se peut
peut-être le bessat
on n'a pas vu réellement pourquoi pas en
tout cas il est foutu
mais bon je pense que la dernière partie
ça fait mal un bon toucherait même
ouais mais c'est sûr que tout fait mal
au coeur c'est bien joué il est évident
que sur les marques le fond et sylvette
reprend il y aura donné un pion mais
qu'il en est revenu plus tard et le flou
j'ai dû rater très bas
la moye prendre l'espace va sûrement
leur activée par un puits b 5 ou où tu
le mans ces quatre des cinq un moment
c'est juste parfait
bref je suis allemand je vous dis tout
simple et bon il joue vite et bien leur
thèse doit devrait apprécier
je suis mes conseils on peut enfin enfin
c'est hyper logique à l'échec
peut-être fou des cinq tasses ou v5
direct je vais bien je suis 4 chaque
époux dessin ou b 5 to black le cavalier
quand même je comprends la vidéo si tu
crois peut-être fait retour des trois et
six au revoir ton cavaliers tu seras
obligé de tout est changé en fait il ya
d'autres jeux c4 après pour fixer le
foot alors une torah 5 ou quoi je me
tais toi mètres la tour en d5 fait les
jeunes harraga toujours en prison mais
c'est exemplaire et après dans ce cas de
figure une des voix que de 9 cette
qualité sur des sept épreuves étaient
très avancées dans les vélums le simple
bouche à rien surtout attendait 5
logique il va échanger entre eux trois
armements dont on reprend si c'est trop
c4 et c4 plus logique et ça nous a coûté
une autre idée non c'est 5 pour ces 4 tu
peux aussi avoir quand même idée de
voyage a été dur de faire geagea chez
tout rejet en russie est passé de
l'autre côté vous pouvez plus exister on
est bon on espère un joueur qui veut
dire stop kg 5
je crois que c'est juste un rêve qui
deviendra jamais un truc peut-être le
fffc bien joué à la casse de 4 pour le
roi
non mais là en fait c'est le moment où
on galère et contre un mec de ce niveau
peut-être tout réussi ce tour des six
minutes mais sûrement il a doublé 66e
peut être tombé il va encore tomber
ah ouais on s'éclatait four b3 et un bon
ça qu'on s'affaire lorrain déjà +5 et
encore je crois et puis à ses lunettes
mais on peut alors ça ok il est fait
flouer 5 et là il est temps de fou de
talent avait joué ce week-end dans mon
équipe made man et son message le
détroit bizarre hein que noir message
c'est que j'avais analysé pour laurence
dans les championnats d'europe
parce que pure ou ne pouvait jouer ça
éventuellement mais non vous appelez 12
du tout ça c'était ça vatine espagnol
l'onf ou deux pas plus haut comme toi
petite ligne mais jouable pour les mains
au tube et saint cyrice et casper son
prénom
ouais ou le fantôme mais c'est génial
comme prénom excuse moi je ne vois pas
ça serait génial vais voir l'arbitré eut
la partie je ne voudrais pas un
adversaire il a non mais il a su
s'imposer sur rhône
c'est lui donc iyh qui change qui était
champion du monde de d'études rade mais
les polos soins c'est bon de 500 mg
istac était fort aussi mais c'est à la
moustache sympa aussi c'est un équipier
à à montpellier est bon maintenant il
surtout aux entraîneurs quoi mais c'est
un grand maître pas loin de 1625 80 il a
déjà dépassé dès 2006
braga très sympa helios il avait ce
titre qui est plone a aussi peut-être
qui ils sont des petits délires comme ça
bon d'accord mais trop attention parce
qu'on aille g6 un jour tu nas à [ __ ]
en f3 tun et sera en fait ces deux
ententes et des fois je sens qu'il sauve
même de prendre un petit chipeau comme
saint jean mais ce qui va essayer de
ramener le cavalier versé huit décimales
une nouvelle fois un tueur du cavaliere
c'est ça c'est un janus en fait tu
pourrais faire janus des six direct en
fait penser à nice est vraiment fort
d'avoir un janus calme après un vieux
pros kg 6 - plus s'embêter que ce genre
de données jamais pourquoi pas aux 4 kg
5 peut-être bon mon retour et je
découvre encore une fois simple et
normaux à celle ci fait assez efficaces
en fait ils jouent vite et mais là il
est bien nous aurons probablement
position qui est le sien claquer la
qualité l'accession
quoique ya même pas obligé en faites pas
je pense qu'ils claquent médullaire par
là que tu peux même toucher à rien oui
tu peux me lance tu claques mais bon je
pense qu'il est parti pour un mais je
suis jamais trop quoi faire quand je
sens qu'on adore ça va craquer une
qualité et bien ok peut-être il faut
quand même la prendre mais je détache le
genre de positions et les blancs pas mal
vous faut trouver les bonnes ça a changé
le visage de la position bella tombe et
3 qui faisait rien de plus avec le
colisée mais bon et il va obtenir un
combat c'est juste qu'en d3 donc qu'il
est pénible pour les tours mais doit
rendre ni pourquoi il peut rendre en
fonction des trois bons construit aussi
pioncer qui permet on va te les finales
sont excellents pour les noirs donc
fortement gardé les blancs pour les
dames pour le blanc essaie de causer
d'épaulement ce qu'il essaye de faire j
bref pas surtout attaqué grand chose
dans les audiences
la dame rose 5 l'effort de gens et là
tout ranger 3 pas si bien placées elles
seraient mis en b1 peut-être points à 9
ckoi bon pour l'instant des trois tours
troyes ok mais ce qu'on peut faire c'est
cinq peut-être et préparer ses 4 6 3 du
coup ces deux après j'en verrais bien
que forcément mal on en voit ouais bah
pourquoi pas enfin je vois comme pro je
m'en foutais de échanger les dames
hockey 7 choses à savoir bien ce que tu
disais non tiffany l'orne
ouais c'est morgan qui déchantent
adaptation met donc à faire un objet
quatre jeunes ont bon ce ne serait qu il
gardait dame compte qu'un jeu face à
sarah grand chose et prendre l'option à
4 est en fait ils aptes et c'est à toi
et surtout retrouver ce poisson mise
c'est juste ça ça assez misérable non
pas illogique rupture c'est pour rien je
crois assez joli ça met sa menace jusque
matelas pour la peine ce que certains
joueurs ce genre juste tour 8 en force
quand j'ai une force et mettons 8 des
deux hommes et des dieux du cac ait eu
francs g8 s'y reprendre la dame
d'invoquer je t'en fais pas des vins
peuvent faire très vite du coup m'étais
jamais tu ne finis pas j'avais avec un
truc juste normal 3,8 et on abandonne
c'est bon il ya des points qui
t'embrouille qui traîne mais là c'est
quoi le passé pour lui la production
c'est pour rien et donc ça va donc
laisser gagnant pour le magistrat il
s'était démené 4g travail b4y t'enlève
la dame et tu veux plus au fait de pions
c'est de faire tours 4 donc je n'ai
aucune ressource foule est hyper
resourceful ça va avoir un tour
constitue évidemment qui va retenter un
piège mais devant b6 pas mal de changer
truc les tours peut-être bien mais ce
qui va le laisser faire ce qui est bon
piont tu vas me dire et ça tourne encore
mais peut-être tentés tour 8 to russia 1
to ride pour 1,32 où il veut rentrer
quelque part de dame des six semaines
le sens que d'amener sissia et après ces
deux mais je sens qu'il est en train de
mettre en place un truc ouais kg 3 ouais
mais je dors il a bien muselé place
comme d'organiser des 20 secondes en
plus il est pas des patrons crise de
temps mais bon la fin mac à tire la
langue la dame c'est 300 têtes je fais
retour b1 et en franc de 30 m et
peut-être une ne fait pas rentrer les
pièces si tu veux faire damas mais
attention le ressenti un petit truc pour
derrière les tours blanches ont pu soit
premier range et c'est un point faible
ici les statiques lohman ok mais à tours
angers 6 mai au caire non mais vraiment
si tu peux rentrer au final maintenant
une tourte d'éruption 2 tours 17
comme d'hab 4 quoi maintenant n'empêche
ce qui a peut-être faire du fou prend à
4 pouces et six en baisse et ça c'était
un nouveau piège quoi voilà juste roi je
donne on est les rois je vais faire tout
reprend h4 ou la deux ok mais le roi
rose bah ouais je suis à tout projet set
tu te fais ma tei évidemment c'est 3-1
et sur des oeufs de droit je crois
qu'après trois projets cat et puis
d'échec le ratage est atteint m c'est
chaud et dé prendre un bon bain dans le
dos de notre afrique at t il ce cavalier
jouent tous queyranne un bon temps comme
ça ça va paraître folichon pour le
moment oui c'est pas le cas c'est ça le
cavalier dont parlait de l'ade sont à
par l'avant c'est ce qu'avait démenti
par les joueurs et tu vas faire hk tu
maintiens son cavalier 6 escaliers car
la scène il adore depuis que j'ai 4 6 3
un code espaces
il vient taper le cavalier mais un
deuxième arrive
quant à patrick est parti il ya trop
d'écart de niveau bas côté tu pars un
peu fait son match là on va être super
au moment oui c'est en fait ce début qui
s'est fait enchaîner
l'anafé une heure et je crois qu'ils
étaient à -3 il a - 4 enfin c'est chaud
quoi penser que ce sera dupe immense de
scores inverses à la serait hyper
intéressante je dis oui on dit la peur
doit tout donner le machin non tu te dis
c'est ce qu'ont pu l'être il va faire
des poules est manquée j'ai aussi
version mac a un peu baissé de niveau
pas énorme travail mais tu vois qu'il
est moins loin dans l'intensité du début
du match
la raison un c'est pas évident de rester
concentré aussi quand tu mènes jaune de
concentration je suis pas trop aimer le
tour à 6 tours v6 là où j'ai
l'impression que tu vas aller en bo3
ouais mais la colonne quand même fait
rage la sq lycées de la khl arbres ou
caïds et 1 ou cavani pour vendre leur
tour eu huit peut-être un historique et
lycées 4 non théorique et ces 15 ne
marchait pas ce que tu prenais b deux
sur les failles non mais je peux
comprendre son idée mais c'est sur faut
pouvoir prendre soit le nommer en fait
si tu mets une foule cet été deux
soutiens peu mal les cases ça me fait
toujours peur d'envoyer une tour comme
ça ouais mais je la mettrais permettra
enfin il est parti pour un prêt une fois
que tu es parti pour tes obligé mais à
peine leurs dessins qui a pas du tout
comme ça en battant non mais ça va pas
être mauvais en plus le fouillis protège
alors s'attaquer à d'autres buts si par
moments il y avait deux frères bon fond
et le peuvent a un coût des fois il faut
dégager la tourbe est ronde et il
empêche b5 aussi ouais mais bon le foot
va pouvoir revenir en b 6 7 ans et 7 ans
fait f4 vous dire je reviens pour éviter
donc il est trop rien en échange une
saga plus de primes pour entre histoire
colonna juste le roi va tenir les cases
trois jouets neufs ou snacks et je
préfère fois trois fois parce que c'est
un jeu oui c'est assez joli ça ok mais
juste
à l'heure actuelle non il fait le puzzle
rachat font avec du coup une bonne idée
sur le papier
pour lui ça marchait pas à cause de
petites touches de la cnam et que tout
est fluide je ne vois rien bon même si
sa str6 claire des compensations pour
les noirs il ya des vraies compensations
doivent être suffisantes pour tenir
d'ailleurs des cas mais en fait je veux
pas prendre le pion il veut s'inquiétait
être surpris en point il fait tour à cet
échec au passage est fou prend les
quatre après rue89 dans ok pas mal comme
un bon bah prendre trompe pas derrière
ce succès on détient 4 ou 6 o'clock
ailleurs il devra d'être haut en bts
qu'on peut le maintenir ce tour à deux
coups des inrocks ne tient pas trop
souffrir ces 4 verra donc et les six réf
mais j'avais auto reprend points 4
passes qui a passé par avec du tour à 8
et tourbe évident pour le bon 80 mais je
crois que sauf à l'effet retour à 8h08
excellent néons tour à lui trois des
sept tours v8 fois cinq peut-être
j'ai souffert cédé une fois avant oui et
c'est en rade au kelly des cv trois
tours à 802,3 bel honneur ouais autour
des ouais c'est bien jouer catwoman est
fou c'est cathy s'en fout en fait ma
tempe et de prendre au tour ces deux oui
pour une autre il ferait un jour aussi
qu'il peut le prendre faire des quatre
dessins et pour des caves m'étais pas
pressés a déjà tour à cet homme s'est
quand même fait à l'embarras du choix
toi tu coupes leroy tourner vers 17
contre les options mais après tout que
changeant ces cas très rares des cinq
tout le roi n'était pas passé les pions
je pense qu'il est en train juste de
calculer jusqu'au bout là
ok puis en ce jour de finale est-ce que
laurence et 4 x 4 le patron n'a tour et
puis appuyez ont dépassés surtout un qui
est un problème ça va refaire +51 femmes
et en plus t'as pas fou pour défendre
puis à tours 2 donc tu perds tout et
plus gf des crashs de l'avenir donc
l'attenté fou j'ai 3 mai à tort ses 5
ouais enfin une conversation privée de
300 inquiète avant de nabeul nord-est 4
3 ok donc il a un milieu marche avant il
à nouveau à +5 ya trouvé le temps dans
cette portion
il reste c'est un quart d'heure un bon
quart d'heure je crois à temps il reste
un gros carré des trois organes goes the
world turns l'autre et féroé fuite et je
connais pas bien la théorie là-dessus
c'est un peu bizarre pour les noirs mais
pour n'agace pas mal pour son style en
fait il y ont assez chaotique assez
bizarre la paire de foot et on a tout à
l'heure pour un peu de misère mais bon
tu as caché un jour ils utiliseront très
bien ce qu'il fait depuis le début du
match ça peut le prouver
après moi je préfèrerais jouer tes
blanche position justin c'est dur à
jouer un des affaires droit des sept
mers à 17 tours et oui c'est sûr devant
garder cinq points ce temps on descend
ça paraît très bien roulé blanc ça qui
est bien trop naïve ou fertile des
frères guissé je comprends mais vous
même moins cinq as the saints qui bloque
yvelines ils attaquent le fouet f6 est
hyper bien joué
c'est violent capital et 8 ans a trouvé
en blitz
non mais le truc c'est que nikon est
enfin là et quand bien même il y avait
des centaines aux équidés set je pensais
que tu bouffes eux reprend baysa wintour
hui 3 ses 8
c'est sûr ça dans gawker fait des bonnes
et ça il absolument de fortifier son
fief si ce qui permet de plonger sa
d'équitable au prétoire g8 face au fait
des trucs intéressants mais ne s'est pas
un moment il va se rendre à fouday vite
en fait je te sens un statut peut le
virer directeur est fou des 4 je suis
pas sûr que tu vois c'est chaud quand
même de voir même des managers c6 ou des
vies tout ça même si tu connais tu vois
il s'en fout tout ça vite quand même
mais très fun et puis fait des trucs
qu'on peut voir en piste bleue fait sans
heurts oui bien sûr dans mais joe price
et qu' il le fait à bon escient
il faut juste sur le poteau ou foulée 6
mais bon ok c'est pas encore
complètement fini les ennuis piste à
calais b 3 qui peut arriver avant mais
moi faire bicis va essayer de colmater
un peu ton petit peu mais après le coup
j'ai cinq pour leur âge si ce bon
boitier sa fiche un peu vain elle va
faire le tour et trois sets 6-3 6-7 sûr
on rase et 7 passes il n'ya pas faut
cinq dons
après bon pas se prendre de chico donc
si je peux je préfère mettre la classe
sans bloquer la terreur d'alger trois
projets 7 200 m dames prendre l'astuce
qui était fou 5
je pensais qu'ils avaient fait un truc
genre fous ces 8 et ou non mais c'est
fantastique vous anime le fou qui fait
le tour de l'échiquier peut-être fou
pranger s'ajuste way et je crois que
4,24 je te faire [ __ ] en d4 peut-être
te forcer à prendre et de faire pouët
5,5
ok peut-être 38.8 epyon g7 reste en vie
le plongeur est replongé souhaite ouais
voilà les noms et sarah il me manque un
tel geste
non non il manque un tempo parce qu'en
fait tu vas faire dame prend 1,7 en plus
ce qui va faire très plaisir ça fait
très plaisir d'enregistrer videmment se
souvient à f/5 prix c'est dommage c est
maintenant ou g5
mais bon dommage c'est aussi l'idéal
mais il faudra pas faire injure aux
nippons leur viande à mach 4 comme je
travaillais damage prix de formule 1
brawn se tient tous les menaces matin
oui mais est-ce que ton un grammage 5e
forum
voilà la f4 c'est bien quelqu'un 26,6 en
d3 et j'aurais trouvé c'est de l'un des
mets qui réussissent à l'air bien aussi
mais quelle 6 tu perds un pion pas est
ce que tu peux h3c simplifié au mieux et
dans les faits invoqués il prend pas la
f4 d'un premier quatre dames 6 7 3 6
voyant ça va voilà ce que je sais de
ramon gagnant je sais pas quel coup faut
jouer mais ça va être une au même âge
400 m il ya peut-être eu quatre poutres
en i 6 dames franchissait la barre mais
ça que je vous fais savoir me stresse
pas complètement de faire comme dame
moqué sur damas six il veut faire fouet
si ces dames croatie suspense est
dommage de 6,2 me g8 mais c'est pas mal
c'est un peu avant non mesdames justine
henin no 3 d'al 3 1 0 h 1 d'un match 3
voilà qu'il y aura quelque chose il fait
leur loue alors beau boubou moyens
privés 4 ok il vous prend du site
apprend des cadres mes chèques non mais
nous laisse jamais tranquille quoi
ballester vous franchement c'est beau ce
qui faire ce que tu as la dame de cette
affaire roissy ce qui est c'est 3 à 5
ok il ya minimum fou prend 1,6 d'un vol
avec arme dans le iv ok mais ça prend
des capteurs à tous rêvent de bloquer
peux déjà te faire tout un échec et dame
prend g7
c'est horrible quoi il va te faire
tourner quatre hockey tour 4 a encore
h33 autour d'eux on croit qu et manon
damas trois et maintenant on n'a plus
rien en plus avec les blancs nous rien à
moins d'un projet d'un procès de six
tours de cette c5 g5
je sais pas mais il vient sans promo roi
à quoi tout le temps ok il a raté il a
raté deux matchs 16 sur trois principes
et d'un match 7
je pense il a pas vu qu'elle arrive à
avoir des trous arrivées des trois sets
pour eux deux il va réussir à damas en
premier ok les tours de magie prend la
femme est aussi mais c'est c'est double
si sûr double six cantons peu plus voilà
tu peux pas faire grand chose vous
tentez un écart de niveau c'est un peu
comme pour comme pour caruana quoi on
parle a du mal à tous que d'autres
conseils qu'on veut on fait front témoin
phare qui peut ce que tu veux et
justement farc
bah ouais c'est tout un est moins forte
et moins fort
tant pis un peu plus tôt un match pas
trop mal hors norme un peu longues
pattes non mais je pense que le match
qui fait il est plus qu'honnête contre
dacca ouais c'est un match plus
connaître non en fait peu de temps mais
là où nakaa quand même une paire bien
accroché c'est que qu'on travaille à
neil ferme pas du tout le jeu qu'on
pourrait dire qu'ils auraient plus
intérêt joie des positions simple machin
est pas rentré dans le combat en 5000
trois minutes
en fait ils jouent le match ils jouent
sans calculer en fait ce match aurait pu
advenir la wepad calcul de ventre et par
oui non mais le de stratégie de oui oui
je pense
il ferme pas le jeu il envoie juste mais
faisait 3 mach 1 h 4 h 53 300 sans
pression puisque avec les north
davantage de la structure mais les bons
la peur de fou il ya match tu as qui est
bien c'est que en fait c'est sur le
score que le match il est il est pas
cool mais sinon sur le contenu c'est un
trouve c'est un très bon match mais ce
ne sera pas le parti à chaque fois et le
royaume avec la défense il ya minimum 3
4 belles parties vraiment belle qui
était h3g 4 on voit où j'ai bien
c'est peut-être dames 3 efforts nom il
prendrait firme cahier g7 mais peut-être
une idée pour 8 auquel il doit juste
vouloir faire nul
we battent à petit et pas mieux mais bon
ok go si ce n'est pas tant de faire
gaffe qui veut faire foi et cissé puis
le tram la tour sera colonna
voyez encore deux trois petits trucs à
gérer prévoir ça sur ses besoins très
saine même mais je veux faire des trucs
comme ça je pensais que j'allais faire
quoi que si tu fais gaffe film est assez
petite frange est ici maintenant mais ça
va oui avant et bien sûr il veut faire
je comprends pas trop ce qu'ils veulent
faire et cleveland n'en est rien
maintenant je pense que tu as plus de
soi et non à ces gars là il va peut-être
faire f 4g car tg5
enfin c'est à ton roi avec les noirs
n'étaient pas signés en fait tu as plus
de cases ouais mais s'il faut à 620
chevaux pour ça je faisais couler faire
est vrai mais bon le roi aurait pu
partir en russe est donc en jeu raconter
n'importe quoi alors jusqu'à 3,8
peut-être g4g ktef celui qui utilise
environ g7
bon je vous dirais mais ça va en fait
nan mais tout est noir alors gestion
mais comme d'hab industries' si tu te
dis c'est bon film ne ré direct à te
force à résoudre de nouveaux problèmes
c'est peut-être pas très grave mais
juste te laisse pas juste aller retour à
deux que l'iac atlantique ont bien joué
mais les bannis en fait les vannes ya
des partis jouent vraiment bien mais il
n'arrive pas à tenir aussi longtemps le
niveau d'exigence de naka quoi cela tu
vas y tient bien ils aillent tous les
problèmes en fait ils récusent prenez
ces deux parties une autre quand bien
même quand il est règle il gagne pas
tout le temps et puis un moment donné
naka il en pose juste trop il explose en
fait fait il le fait exploser nombreuses
bon d'accord la met tour cette fois à
troyes tombé six tournois il va lui
piquer son c2 alors après actuel
comprend 24 c'était bien et maintenant
ok bon il essaie de tenir constamment
maintenant sur ces beaux coups sûrs et
n'a plus aucun doute là dessus
wade 17 tomber cette poussée 7,6 il va
tenter des coups g3 machin mais bon
voilà y'a rien mais c'est la touche
étoile c'est peut-être même pas
émetteurs français est râleur mais bon
mais bon maintenant pour qu'elles
prouvent aussi que les noirs parce qu on
est un peu bloquée taxi qu'elle est à
fuxin amphoux g3 ça on va récupérer les
c3 et ça va aller
ce qu'on perdrait vii mais c'était pas
si grave peut-être à mettre le pion à
finhan non mais ça va aller là je pense
femmes aux lèvres a gagné papin s'est
pas encore progression tomber cette
peut-être il va refaire tours à huit ou
neuf à dix en moins nombreuses cette
image il est chiant je sais pas si sûr
mais bien sûr qu'il est pénible
il est vraiment trop fort
voilà
ouais c'est étonnant non ça tellement
l'impression d'atteindre d'une pression
de notre gagnante
il va découvrir assez facilement quoi
mais surtout que ça la position du père
était dans une position gagnante et qui
est assez facile à tourner en tout cas
en blitz étudie votre latin attendait du
tout quoi ouais mais c'est là que tu
vois la différence de niveau aussi c'est
que quand il est en difficulté elle y
défend alors si la photo donc il repart
sans quelque 400 fait pas le détroit
cette fois ci soit déjà joué une partie
basse a salué la qualité ben oui exact
les vont donc fois c'est un tour à trois
tours b3 machin comme ça
j'allais dire je peux peut-être envie
car il y eu quatre rangs des quatre ma
chambre
on voyait le beau jeu quoi ça marchait
pas du tout mais c'était pour un pour
envoyer quoi il aime bien son petit
voisin de choix stratégiques 4 qui
enchaîne les housses sympa souhaite
acquérir 25 du coup il domine un peu le
cavalier en a cinq qui a pu les cases on
n'a pas eu ce genre quasiment la même
position de talât un truc vraiment mes
gars en blanc mais là le fou en cinq
pôles chevalier et j'allais dire ben
hamman je prendrais plutôt les blancs
voient la suite je choisirais la
position après un effet vous avec les
noirs y va quand même nous faire c6 c7
un moment il va se réactiver n'avoir way
n'est pas du tout vers tours 4 et sur
qui des trois tours et 4,6 me faudra
trois pas mal placée ce qui n'empêche
sur la fuite mais d'un autre côté faire
attention qui se retrouvent par joe kay
par contre le point 4 il va souffrir non
je pense qu'on va bien ce truc là après
peut-être temps celle du cavalier c4i
titeux des loges le cavalier il le
protège et on peut pas faire pour
prendre quatre tours inquiets ces quatre
dom à deux épreuves 5,2 me prend le
sisto reprend le 6 34 98 quoi surprendre
qu'un pion 34 d'un malin toi qu'est et
ses valeurs quel point le 5 prend deux
points 6 passes
bon il ya peu famille est temps qu'on me
cataloguer toutes et tous et je peux
confinement ouais de mon psychiatre kf3
tu comprends ton contre le groupe point
final c'est un peu du même acabit ans
qui fait un nom mon petit doigt les
problèmes de justesse à eux
une poêle juste le temps et regarde je
reste 2 minutes 40
mais cette histoire pour mieux le sud
non mais ça c'est sûr qu'ils aient ces
quatre noms l'armée fans c'est
impressionnant j'ai réussi un rare au
nian j'ai envie de te dire en sifflotant
quoi c'est presque un concours de
vitesse il avait fait la même chose
contre mvl d'ailleurs m'ont donné il
s'était mis à jouer très vite un
attention je peux faire fois c'est
impossible
à 17 ans il est tous ces longs qui
reculent il reste 45 secondes dans la
section 5 + 1 donc très
vraisemblablement ce sera la dernière de
trois puits saint pardon est très belle
et très vraisemblablement ce sera la
dernière partie de de la cadence donc
avant les bulles est au mieux à royal il
va tourner à -5 et c'est parti pour
notre dame ces quatre prochains coups
ont donc attaqué trois et ça c'est menu
rend plus tout ça mais tu as dame d un
jour j si si le voit tempo tu avais même
pas besoin de réfléchir mais ça paraît
peut-être un détail pour vous mais mais
mais pour moi ça veut dire beaucoup quoi
mais en mai il te met la pression autant
quand il fait ça en plus
zhai jun tempo et avait la pression
modèle dominant plus sa position
le fonds pour financer cette un moment
on fait un peu des menaces soient
longues diagonales noir c'est peut-être
enfin je pense ça va pour les plans à
peu près mais les soucis tout le temps
tout le temps il ne fait que ça en fait
donc les 88 aussi peut être un moment
bon faut défendre ou 4 ça peut être un
souci aussi s'il nord font tour à huit
tours à deux entre apparente d'amener
cinq retours un jeune apparaît que lui
menace b4
capital fr tourrades vraiment un bon
choix mais ça vachement d'avril quand
même tenté bref c'est trop 6 3 des 5
une épopée by the tempo contre des
sacrifices en trois sets
j'ai gagné trois titres est long voyage
cinq ou six qui va traîner et des amis
qui se transforme alors g5 et des 5
c'est peut-être aussi présentés ok mais
bonne gestion du match de la part de
naka banalité plutôt mieux mais pas mal
défendu
non mais c'est c'est fantastique et l'on
sait combien de temps le bellâtre une
demi heure 20 minutes 38e but let's 30
min 38 et ça devrait rapidement
commencer un d'accueil les lycées les
phares n'y a personne qui s'élevaient
d'ailleurs ne démord pas de son choix je
pense qu'il on prend des coups dans le
sens où les bonnes
bon je me dis bon je pense pas qu'il ait
spécialement envie que ça traîne un max
quoi peinture là - si ça avant les avant
le début des bullet tu as il n'est pas
favori non non on a vu des gens plus
favori que les amis avant de mettre le
t-shirt komodo qui te donne beaucoup de
force tu es mal et du coup alors tu as
tu envie de liens du 17 mai mais j'ai
pas trouvé vraiment le tee shirt que je
recherchais gens rien dit charles thomas
daum et mais on en avait vu en mieux
j'ai l'impression que je trouve plus
parce qu'elle en fait c'est un t-shirt
normal pas 5 au mode normal en fait et
vous avez vu un oui d'emblée si c'est
chance pour nous c'est important qu'ils
ont valu double ou six noms bon va même
lui il est bien il sera longuement
petite grimace mais c'est pas évident de
faire des grimaces fasti voilà d'accord
à ménaka il est impressionnant
il est imprenable
pas pour une toile à faire illusion
je donne zéro chance mais j'ai pas mais
ça me dit oui mais ils ont déjà joué
ensemble
ce n'est pas si clair enfin face après
peut-être sam qui me dit ça pour me
vendre le match moi pour qu'on leur
vende nous apprécient les pare balles ou
convaincantes a assuré le niveau il peut
être ils essaient de me convaincre que
pour que je combats les gens que c'est
bien tu vois mais évidemment ça serait
bien j'ai ce sera une boucherie dave dix
noms des six mois je vais d'ici mai mais
hull a vraiment dit non quoi propose
d'un bras-de-fer mais pour savoir qui a
raison
c'est sûr que j'ai raison non de gamine
solitaire monial au collège libermann
exactement c'est à présent le chat
souvent les noms qui finissent par yann
déjà parlé coût apparent réservé pour
son vrai nom stade n'avons rien savoir
j'ai souvent par yann divisé scan
ouais mais mais c'est une grande star
des stars ian wallace est une grande
star yana on n'a rien demandé je crois
que c'est marié là il n'ya pas très
longtemps dire c'est le président du
pays qui qui l'a marié macro niasse et
macro n'ya non exhaustive qu'est-ce
qu'on peut expliquer les ouvertures en
live c'est à dire voilà pour le pilote à
être pas mais je vais pas trouver
s'utilise merci enfin fou c'est dur quoi
parce qu'une version ça me prend
plusieurs heures du mans en plus forme
et comme il joue tout le temps le même
truc après on est parvenu il va
remporter chaque fois une seconde bombe
allez bonne époque ainsi fait déjà cinq
secondes de retard pour qu'on négocie
donc petite caro qui avait déjà joué
plus ou moins donc les blancs
al'avantage le père de chou les noirs
voirie se bat et medicaid mikel irizar
bon ben là c'est sûrement beaucoup moins
non mais ça va ça bat toi tu cette
structure non je joue ça toute ma vie
mais bon tu as toujours un petit passé
pas moins de 3,5 c'est légèrement
désagréable
elle joue très très vite matin il ya
déjà deux secondes à 11,1 résiste bien
ça va très bien pour les vannes de
position mais en fait il est curieux que
jusqu'à vallier parce qu'ils sont kobo
de l'opposition on sait pas attendu
bélanger 5 voilà on y est roi il va
revenir à ménetreuil dans le salon une
fois réparé va changer l'armée ya je
pense qu'il est un peu moins bien parce
qu'elle joue et b6 bras cet ouvrage de
nouveaux cas de figure lequel on s
inquiète très bien on ne peut pas faire
être s'inclinant à faire est de 5 4
tonnes ce qui est des cas de tremblement
tour eu un effet retour d un matelot
bijoux
ça va moi je chante c'est quoi comme
chanson du grand ouest 4 à 8 et en d3
ils épargnent un pion demain à la
bagarre pour prendre la mesure de huit
échecs
je pensais qu'ils arrêtent la tour en d4
c'est des chances des chances pour
appuyer son pion et puis on évoque les
rachats vont peut-être faut quatre sites
une option moment ok des six logique et
inbee mes affaires d'état
cette fois je trouve ces six apprennent
à mel evans bien rire ça sonne bien
n'attendez d'oliva de t&d 1 c'est quoi
ça il veut prendre ses trois missions
soit 800 pence en croire ces quatre
failles s'assoit sur le 8 à 2 à 2 31 un
tour à tour j'ai vite et d'ailleurs g8
non je vais faire tout rejet 8 battue
verte orbite en fait je t'en faut juste
à tétouan de fous j'ai 2 et damman fort
ton tour prendre pour baby jet à et non
t'as raison
ouais tourbe évidemment ne met alors à
14 août était trop près de 9,6 dans nos
stades de nos banques airways froid ne
me croirait qualité de faire ralentir
les québécois cette fois on prend un axe
est un procès quatre et on va embêter
les noirs parce que watch quatre cent
mille habitants pour qu'ils ont
découvert c'est génial ouais c'est
impressionnant non voyez-vous khatami
tendiez bien sûr le cavalier tempo et
que y'avait rien
il va placer un dôme ercis un moment
bien senti il faut 4 fallait pas
déchaînant mais il a l'impression ces
conditions la villette et affaire d'armé
vidame pranger si c'est fini mais on
sentait qu'il en fait
la potion borne t il à la turn
paraissait une démonstration de farce et
il renonce de faire de la bas-rhinoise
peut-être tient la balle et on n'a pas
eu encore ça faisait longtemps c'est
bien parce bien ou pas pourquoi pas eu
l'occasion
ça me dérange pas c'est devant un match
entier a que cette position là ça change
et ont récupéré le chronomètre à vince
mendoza strauss théorie quoi c'est sûr
que quand maxime il a déjà eu ce genre
de trucs enfin j'ai perdu le lui à
rennes ii du chronomètre un ben je sais
pas moi j'ai jamais vu et je vais
demander tu as commenté deux ans que
j'ai demandé au patronat n'ont qu'une
jeu tourache ou 8 10e place et je pense
qu'une occasion juste scène avec rhinois
quant à 5 peut-être encore poussé 5 ok
mais bon
pourtant les deux petits le statu quo
convient non surtout quand il fait à
prendre ces cavaliers prend et blanc
pendant les 6 apporte pas grand-chose
d'assurage et prend donc garde champions
peut-être faire aux six un jour
peut-être autre chose ok c 3 mais ouais
écouter sa manoeuvre sa manoeuvre se
passe pas grand chose
selongey retrouvé derrière barreau me
donc et gf j'imagine très confuse
d'options mais pour faire qu'a lieu
cette fois je quatre peut-être qui prend
1 et prend le 5e ferké 5 et km h
mais bon par action de plus avec les
blancs mais non de l'activité
ok pranger 3,5 un moment où tout rachat
je fais des cats échec mais il veut te
prendrai avec le fou peut-être et faire
qui a aidé 6-3 f5 quelque chose comme ça
et b4 des quatre tours h1 way
photo richard de l'esprit ne rien faire
tout rage 2 peut-être tour à deux mais
ok bon je trouve les poireaux oignons il
vous faudra quand même faire justin
willimon de mentionner la même que tu
fais tour des trois tours à deux mais je
pense qu'on va être bon
ouais bon nul nul comme à la fin des
blancs sont offert un petit truc me
passe mais il joue à valence bull est un
nom m'amuse bien non mais il fait son
match en fait mais juste surfer en face
aux méchancetés miss liqun mais qu'est
ce qu'il fait et d'avoir le couteau
matic
oui c'est sûr il n'a pas pu mettre fin à
toutes les seurrois le cliquez sur dame
ne soit le pion des ouais ça c'est sûr
et il habite à la loupe automatique sur
dsk
bah je pense ouais je suis quasi sûr que
ça existe bien sûr que j'y pense et
c'est pour ça que je perds je ne dis pas
jusqu'à dix suivantes ira dans
paramètres machin s'il existe le coup
mode automatique en fait c'est quand tu
cliques sur une pièce qu'elle a qu'une
seule cadre peut aller lille a tempo
donc ça al'avantage d'aller vite pour le
but la tvh ou quoi d'après le défaut
c'est que si là tu cliques sur ton roi
ben vas-y d'accueil d'autres magazines y
va et donc c'est cool aussi des fois
pour défendre un échec
genre une dame en a sept en échec et
courageux suite que faire j'ai cette
image statique donc pour le mieux être
très pratique mais très dangereux mais
très dangereux parce que
moindre coup de souris où je voulais pas
faire non pas un pion qui avance jean
latapie son pur affichage cinq fois tout
était toujours à 5 2 dans lequel j'ai
cinq en tout cas maca est il arrivé à
sortir deux prennent une position
raisonnable
wen en bullet c'est pas si grave de même
très fort non mais disons que tu es ici
tu es vraiment plus fort que ton
adversaire en bus là tu tu peux te
remettre sûreté pas quoi bon les vannes
qui a beaucoup d'activité mais bon il ya
un pion de moi et eu assez de gens
n'étaient pas là c'est le seul défaut
que je trouve au jeu sur internet c'est
possible mais ce clic peut pas penser
qu'à partir du jeu c'est juste de voter
c'est agréable
après l'aipac à haute voix la deuxième
côte est qui peut être chiant c'est
toujours l'histoire l'autriche mais eux
contre des joueurs du top niveau je suis
content parce que au moins y'a pas ces
problèmes là il peut pas se défoncer
leur réputation leur carrière pour faire
des idiots donc dans vieux parfois elles
ont fini loin de partir de cette tournée
plutôt pour les forges ou ercole le jeu
sont atteintes avec des prix et des
machins joue bien mais est-ce que là je
pense saraiva il a du mal à récupérer de
karachi maintenant c'est bon il va fin
comme une tour plus les gens
il n'a pas survécu à son à son explique
non ça valait vraiment le scénario se
situe à + 6 il reste rester dans l'est
dans les clous à bas prix il est à un an
et demi et demi pour l'instant
belote à la surprise générale c'est un
budget qui tient le mieux après la
thérapie depuis celle qui a joué juste
trop lentement alors ils puissent plus
dû faire confiance à son instinct
puisqu'il a eu beaucoup de positions il
était très mal autant c'est une
pollution a déjà eu à quelque chose près
mais je crois qu'on l'a eu qu'à peine 2
4 il avait fait dame réussisse je
pensais la même une fois trois noms et
photos entre 4 et tu vois là peut-être
qu'il faudrait jouer plus vite toile et
vie changeons que des pôles monde ok
mais l'enfer le fond ça s'appelait maria
nagorny on n'a qu'à l'euro n'y a ni bac
à sable peu trop non être 4g très sympa
ouais j'avais pas vu très bien joué en
fait ils donnent des deux ne peut quoi
bon gamer est juste raconter en fait
c'est trop gagnant mais on peut finir
maker est jamais chose chose aisée mon
nom sans sueur a tout de suite hein mais
je les bats tu as en arenaria pas si
longtemps bullet naka j'ai mis en sueur
court toujours
tout le monde peut y arriver tant les en
train via en train de faire une tête de
côté et irréfléchie un truc rester juste
fini qua non mais il va pas je me la
pendule à vif la pendule en fait non
c'est petit ça hikaru n'ont pas combattu
même si la marge de 6 et 8 16 bits
adam prend le nom m'échappe à 3 h 23
non il fait des grimaces de partout
maïs et des grimaces mais ça c'est moche
mais veulent surtout vente aussi la
route
bah oui il est large
macy's en fait ok c'est comme la
pression de nul de carlson 1 12e
non mais après mon jeu pensé great food
qui avait initialement donné ici ne veut
pas que ça arrive tu n'as qu'à être
devant au score
enfin il a mal est orné d'un côté je
peux tout rose à 17 ce nom des trucs
comme ça paraît donc proposé 17 mais
j'arrivais une grande proposition
j'avais fait leur effet un très long
mail avec les sept un très très long
mail le nombre witch ou l'autre comptant
ouais c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
non non ils m'ont dit que c'était bien
et m'ont dit que c'est un format qui
utiliserait peut-être pour d'autres
événements qu'ils étaient très heureux
mais juste là ça ne devrait pas être
utilisé que le partenaire at which c'est
en fait ils ont un truc entend dire que
dans ce genre 3h15 quoi ils disent voilà
voilà pour s'allumer en ce temps là
alors des fois le match d'une heure etc
liées et nous seront proposés kevin pour
l'intérêt sportif ne semblait plus bas
plus parce que non quoi se faire des
sets en fait
et puis c'est tout quoi puis comme ça
c'est très compliqué des matchs furent
longtemps alors c'est plié dès le début
pour qu'elle dise 0,3 comme un ak contre
oui fans ça permettrait aussi créé plus
de retournement de situation parce qu'en
fait si tu as une baisse de régime
tu vois il pourrait très bien avoir 14 à
9 mais qui est un set partout
ce serait possible comme aux délices que
tu persistes d'euros le ca trù 7 6 et
puis là non plus le match ça fait
tellement longtemps qu'ils à +4 +5 plus
six mais ça fait genre une heure ou quoi
une heure et demie met donc en réalité
il aurait perdu le premier set et y aura
un tie break dans le deuxième et
peut-être même demain de 7,1 pour les
vols bon sûrement pas mais j'en parle
théoriquement c'est impossible
du piment et s'enlèvera les trucs
inutiles quand c'est trop un carnage
qu'inutile parce que bateau qu'un
spectacle c'est juste un joueur qui
porte sa croix
tout le long du construit comme ça quoi
on peut juste plus non plus les vannes
il revient à fond fallait plus 5
il va peut-être venir à +4 là le fleuve
trois magnifiques bloc le roi crée des
réseaux de maths éventuellement
reprocher ça ils font quoi ça vaut un
truc fou des cinq mais pourquoi prendre
un point c'est bien raconté fois que je
vous prends pas je comprends absolument
pas bon après y'a quand même beaucoup
d'heures de joueurs donc sa méthode à
moitié qui puisse y avoir des petites
scories dans le jeu et pousse son purin
très bien joué tour des 5 1 est
peut-être fait retour des quatre
français 4 et mais ça va faire nul
moquer comme pro 2 500 gagne en ce
moment donc je dis vent et vlad flotte
soit flat je suis pas sûr qu'il serait g
anosy toutes ses finales n'en mets avion
c'est évidemment ça favorise l'attaquant
par rapport à qui on annonce que le
droit est plus proche fournira les
blancs d'être sacrifiés en fait que
revient que défendre votre normalement
pour moi c'est niang
ak il est venu défendre avec le roi
proche du fion ce qui semble dire que
ces gagnants
il y aura des 5 comparé à 4 6 4 1 0 et
4-4 et non mais c'est bien ça je
l'aurais fait retour si cet échec une
fois plus et là le roi est coupée donc
c'est ok naka sport cette fois ci a
donné 50 2 au bond
m
mathématiquement c'est encore foutu pour
l'union il reste quatorze minutes ou
annoncé encore voir plus haut niveau
cette remise en partie ils vont faire 5
il ya quatre points de retard évidemment
la moindre défaite c'est fatal niveau de
faire une nulle
il faut tout gagner non mais assez assez
étonnant que qui reviennent en ville est
en fête là on l'attendait le moins c'est
là où il est le plus fort maintenant
plus ou alors c'est un cas qui craquent
total mais tu vois sinon quand il joue
comme ça en bullet demain tout est
jouable pour soha kneen histoire peut
soit que où il proposait la filiale
chaise quand on la doit vous poserez
hockey des cinq nouvelle fourchette
non mais c'est un cadenas qui craquent
magath qui craquent ils encore il vient
encore de file une pièce mais il y une
pièce mais conviennent que si la filiale
en bullet bain une fois parti je zoome -
enfin celle d'avant non il a juste peur
du proc parti en contre mais final four
c'est un accord qui permette au plus
vite et puis en fait
c'est pas un saint ok les poubelles
hilare pas trop mal réussi par il part
de très loin dans ses poubelles un grand
prix de france et feront de 3 oui c'est
moins le malin les vannes a quand même
eu ni ricard ou quand même sur la caméra
web et la chambre d'amis bombay 3 quand
même mais bon
dames 1 [ __ ] non mais ça dans vos
attentes des trois dames un tourin ouais
mais tu auras tu n as rien au foot toile
de fous moins vite mais oui mais j'ai un
petit rouge la tour et tu mens pas la
dame non non dick bon là au québec
depuis leur venue menaces qualifiées de
attention quand même à temps mais ce
prompt que voilà mes jeux qu'on voyait
pas quelqu'un essaie de laisser finir
alors heureuse mais l'extrait rage pas
et fait 5 ou voulu tout défonce la ilaha
illa tilt de folie a fait une foire deux
miss ligue au caire devait pas de fonds
distincts mois déclaré l'atrix fresh
princess et le sipal et là je crois que
je pense qu'il a déjà gagné le match on
note le type me +5
ouais ouais je pense dans ces conditions
la puissance je pense à gagner le match
en d4 est simple schiphol sont vu les
pièces vers son rang en f1 et pas mal de
roms la grave barret
va faire d'apprentis et 5 bat à la
tournée en juin à 8 heures en l'air mais
je fais car bien qu'elle soit plus rien
passé finit pas ok et compter trois
heures d'affilée comme ça joue vite et
j'ai toujours des pressions différentes
si simple surtout quand c'est pas très
schématique mais bon même si l'on fait
vraiment beaucoup de fautes là ans à la
fin on fait énormément d'erreurs
ah oui la fatigue ça tu sois du rugby et
des jeux kg 3 9 kg 3 3 et 4 ok je peux
comprendre
bon bien pour un rognon il faut une
rupture âge peut-être mais ça va un peu
une robe en fait
ouverture bon ça dans le rôle de
contrôle compris tourner ici je ne vois
pas l'intérêt en fait d'échanger
lecavalier eux deux et de se faire
bouffer c'est cette façon qu'on va en
fait bravo également
oui mais bon tu sais que tu pouvais
prétendre à quelque chose
la toiture est enfin si tu prétends à
terme ça va
non mais bon je veux dire c'est plus
facile à jouer avec les plans quoi pour
du bullet un bon ça à faire nul parce
qu'il ya rien il va faire tout race a
été pour à 2,7 aura trois dans des 84 3
clubs
ouais bon ok ils tous ont pu ensuite où
on pousse partout
ok ça va changer ça à faire nul le bois
sont les patrons bep cap man
bizarre achètes tu auras de dunkerque
nord et l'arnaqué ce qu'il ait mis
autant mais il va pas réussir vous
montre ça va bien tu sens qu'il aurait
aimé jouer quoi rire et attend la fait
son truc il boit de l'eau afin non mais
alors que le match est fini à quoi y'a
plus cinq mais six minutes
donc c'est fini quoiqu'il se passe
non en fait on devrait la mettre des
pénalités alors mais bon c'est dans les
règles s'il veut le faire fin oui eh bah
tu te situes tu fais un contrat si tu
joues à ça on parle pas 1% du hockey
mais c'est très subjectif c'est
difficile d'écrire une règle comme ça il
a raté ranger 3 ans je suis encore d'un
cran voilà il va la perdre c'est génial
il est dégoûté il rigole on rigole de
folie la laisser mourir amène et ramène
levée le 10 avril du moteur prend 1,6
pour à 3 tu peux pas prendre à chaque
échec donne parfaite prend des cassettes
qui est tombé gâteau tu peux pas ici
sera là aussi on peut le prendre mais
d'autres large et roscoff vincent collet
sur dur mais je pense que tu peux le
gagner en force propre fin
il va nous surprendre encore apprendre à
y apporter une vraie mixité farhan haq
et comme sacha se rappelle dans un
speech est ce légal proposé nul est
juste y penser que cet abandon il avait
accepté par mécha mécaniquement genre
vivre un truc qui arrive hirohiti
coiffard offre mais pas si j'ai repris
son vrai nom foutu genre dame de moins
aux clippers actes graves ok mais là tu
vois pas jouer quoi non mais
mais bon t'as le droit
peut-être une patate dans ta gueule
aussi j'ai le droit
après la le match est fini c'est autant
plus moche de stations il reste six
minutes
nathalie ziyi hills où il y aussi génial
tour sans être un couple belge il a
juste fait un très bon match et a bien
joué là en suisse il a gagné à hilla il
a pas besoin
ah oui bah tu as besoin de faire ça
c'est il n'y a pas besoin
alors c'est comme au foot quand tu es
quand tu mènes que 1-0 et tu vas au
poteau de corner et de perdre du temps
mais c'est comme si tu es au foot une
4-0 sur la 91e ouais ça quand ils jouent
du joug et puis voilà tu vas pas au
poteau de corner quand même et là c'est
pas de rire et je comprends en fait j'ai
pas de nouvelles parties rien et essayer
de regagner du temps en faisant semblant
de pas faire rivage que c'est génial
ah oui j'ai déjà fait des grimaces et
tout genre je ne comprends pas pourquoi
la partie ne commence pas à face à un
génie n'a en fait ce qui est bien c'est
qu'il ya tellement pas besoin de le
faire
c'est génial c'est génial mais c'est
exactement ce que tu dis c'est une n 4 0
on avait 92e l'arbitré a sifflé dans une
minute et roule par terre et je
comprends ça tient 0,2 s'est resserré
avec poussée que clément d'arrêt contre
m j'avais fait des comptes révèle jean
il est très dangereux il y avait que 3 4
points d'écart il restait 13 minutes ok
mais là pas mécaniquement il pourrait se
lever de son ordinateur est pas encore
aujourd'hui ce ton viril et gagnera
kouame truc c'est que les parties doit
pas les parents de minutes l on devrait
trois au moins deux minutes grand
minimum
non mais là ce qui est génial c'est que
non mais là il peut il peut il peut en
fait si je veux juste des coups
n'importe quoi il va récupérer au moins
30 secondes et c'est largement à son bon
après je pense qu'il va mettre à portée
de main un nom qu'on disait mais bon
c'est vrai que j'ai été un peu
défaillants dans beau monde bullock
était défaillant et ckoi l'escaut rendu
là tu attends je vais les regarder
il est mené 4 2 j'avais vu n'a qu'à
mener mise à part une autre gardienne
contre magnus
oui exact exact ça incroyable un bon
alors
alors pas cinq ils sont fous il va faire
pousser cette en premier mais à ce point
f 4 d'entre eux n'ont pas il a bien fait
dans le fion comme ça ouais souffrait un
peu oui oui ne me fait souffrir les
jarres il a eu raison
boisson il fallait le père d'une manière
ou d'une autre c'est sûrement là moins
que là au moins les pions à l'est la
dame ils sont pas sont pas en danger
mais bon tu allais reste trois minutes
de match jrs maximum trois parties la
fin je sais même pas si c'est même pas
deux je ne m'aime pas moi je pense non
mais je rêve hier si tu te situes de bar
de ton ordi oui non je pense qu'un hack
une derrière ça là parce qu'une partie a
duré à peu près trois minutes entre le
la galère ajoutant qu'elle ferait à
titre a tancé les rajoutant est assez
j'appuie 2043 vraiment une à fond le
bannissent va bien et garde toutes
actives et son meilleur match mais c'est
plus ça d'habitude un peu comme ça bon
voilà ok va pas gagner maintenant mais
je veux dire c'est qu'à une salle
position il la tient bien facile non
mais le scénario du match est
complètement à l inverse de ce qu on
attendait pour ça qu'il aime beaucoup
mieux tenir le 5 minutes et puis quand
bull est il et s'effondrer alors que
maintenant ce que d'un cas et on est
enfant devant le seigneur et qu'est ce
que c'est que ça trop vite maintenant
progresser sur les check for prince
non mais j'ai vu qu'en fait ils veulent
importer du maccio la faire durer 2
ouais je crois qu'il en a marre la
justice alors que le final de roi il
aurait fait nul mais je pense qu'il va
la faire durer le havre infos que rien
n'est pas seul avec des seins est vent
debout mais qu'at-il à savoir donne un
petit g6 un petit g5 comprend de
l'essence
déjà reparti ranger sans doute aimé
laisser faire ça tous les matchs pas
mais bon je peux dire pour avoir regardé
certains de ces stream qui est très
sympa en fait en stream quand il serait
il est très mal même et ces visages ne
donne une mauvaise image en faisant ça
alors que sinon il est supérieur
commentait-il envers son mari avec un
pote je sais pas mais une fois face à
des millions de deux façons j'aime pas
je te fais pas ton adversaire c'est pas
bien tu respectes rien a pour moi c'est
pire que ce que lier les matchs en
attendant si on compare avec le foot
c'est l'appareil qui mène largement au
score et ce constat de faire des jongles
avoir femme honnête ce serait génial ses
iphone et ça qui font se foutent de la
gueule quoi tuer des gens mais une
balade c'est pourquoi tu as de prendre
un tacle au genou oui bon ce serait
super bowl pour le public quand même
mais du coup aller vonn qui gagnent
beaucoup de points en bullet comme s'ils
avaient gagné le match en lui même
laissé deux ans pour chaque année en
prévenant le choix que d'en mieux pour
moi aussi un second set ruff a laissé le
chronomat est finie s'arrêter pour les
4,2 me prend 1,3 mb simple passade
n'était pas manchot jouer comme ça mais
après oui ça change rien au fait qu'il
ait fait un très bon match que sûrement
va gagner demain et que faut-il plutôt
oui ça va danser stream est touours
enfants mais des fois il ya des trucs
bizarres comme la cua des militants pour
gagner du temps je sais pas
ben et aucun terrain et les joueurs de
trois fois mais
mais bon je sais pas ça va faire marrer
de berlines raison parce que je suis un
mec assez sympa en plus pour avoir
entendu des trucs sur lui en privé
sérieux il fait des trucs très bien quoi
après veut pas trop franchement que ça
se sache
donc ils le disent pas publiquement tous
mes mails fed et c'est vraiment un mec
bien en fait c'est probablement le mec
le plus de ma liste de tous le top
niveau en fait ouais c'est ouf en fait
c'est juste que ça le fait marrer ou
quoi parce que c'est un troll ou je ne
sais pas mais en fait il est beaucoup
plus un humaniste que les autres
probablement france parce que les autres
font les nuits il fait vraiment des
trucs fin ils s'engagent vraiment pour
que ça aille mieux tu vois ton nom aller
la gagner mais en fait ça il fait
vraiment des trucs bien et tout juste ya
pas que ça se sache pas ce qu'il fait
comment dire pour nice et paris répond
d'abord on ne fait pas ça pour se venter
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai en fait
foncièrement cherche un mec très bien ça
va sur ses esprits mais tout juste il a
ce côté troll tu vois c'est ce qui
s'était passé tarde à un moment en fait
que ça doit se marrer toi je comprends
mais en même temps c'est un peu ma train
de cracher à la figure de l'adversaire
l'arrivée d'un autre côté les vannes
ceci le premier à venir troller quand tu
perds quand même raconté laurent
d'écrire une partie était mal placé au
championnat du monde et où il vient toi
oui quelle table tu joues enfin vous
pour rester dans les choux qui va passer
le permis à le faire donc ouais mais
c'est des gens en sont déjà sans doute
et c'est pas il doit de faire sa petite
blague comme ça et puis ça marche n'ont
pas de sens mais justement elle a
peut-être peut-être que les vols l'a un
peu chambré chez pas quoi enfin je n'en
sais rien mais mais on ne sait pas se
battre en match remis au camp qui part
favori pour sa bombe
on s'en fout oui mes joueurs c'est pas
méchant
enfin y'a pas mort d'homme quoi juste
j'ai pas autant le roi 2 pourquoi pas
autant de faits de gagner du temps comme
il ya du public et où je trouve ça un
peu dommage mais bon il fait le coup
devant sa caméra il fait le con j'ai pas
ça fait marrer bon tout cas voilà on
espère que ça vous a plu
ce match s'il ya peu mettre en suspens
mais pas mal de parties sympa à voir
nous attaquer à fond au début enac a
très bien défendu il a fait un bon match
ce gros favoris demain contre sommet
écoutez on verra bien 21h01 par contre
le match mais attention même format
c'est pas super bowl
non c'est même format sa 21h ou pas de
suivre la chaîne chess com/fr très
important pour pour avoir les lives
automatiquement ça vous avez les notifs
et puis on se retrouve demain soir il ya
une info importante il ya un truc à dire
que j'oublie bon non je sais pas non je
crois pas on devait mettre une heure en
accord au dos ou duel 100% américain
ouais et puis voilà quoi donc je pense
que tout est dit quoi bon écouter à
demain soir et ma bonne bonne fans sont
à l'étude